...
Alte White Line, wie schnell bist du am Start, ey.
Ich hoffe nicht mal, mein Headset hat aufgehabt.
Haha.
Das war der, das ist das Channel Camping oder was?
Lul
Ach echt ey
Das hatte ich ja nur auf YouTube bisher, dass Leute innerhalb quasi 0,05 Sekunden am Start sind, nachdem ich auf Play gedrückt hab
Oder auf, auf, auf, was drückt man eigentlich?
Play, äh, Start Streaming
Das war nochmal schnell ne Twittermeldung
Oder was, ich muss euch was, ein nicees neues Feature zeigen
Ein richtig nicees neues Feature
Ich glaube ich muss in OBS erstmal den browser wieder ausblenden
Ja, Pock
Sag mal irgendwie
Auf dem zweiten Rechner lag übelst Tastatur Input
Was ist da los?
Warum machts das?
Ah, ich weiß warum, weil ich zwei Streams gleichzeitig laufen hab, das schafft die olle AMD Grafikkarte da nicht drinne
Muss man sich mal vorstellen, ne?
Lul
Oh, wir haben wieder keine Qualitätsoptionen
Ja, gut
Ähm, Twitch, kann man ja leider nichts machen, ne?
Haben wir keine Chance
Pogas, alter
Massive Pogas
Ey, wie lag Twitter, oder ist das nur Twitter was drum rum laggt?
Ich weiß nicht
Das ist Lagrino
Hast du jetzt 100k, ja dann ist es egal ob ich mit 8mbit stream oder nicht
Aber es können halt viele Leute nicht gucken, weil halt Fail und so, ne?
So, nochmal Twittermessage gepostet, jetzt gehts los
Ja, und zwar, also Leute, ich hab, ähm, geile neue Feature eingebaut, muss ich euch mal zeigen
Erstmal muss ich erwarten, dass noch ein paar Leute da sind, weil das ist so Pogu Pogas und alles zusammen
Das wird euch gefallen
Ebenso, ich hab's ja schon angekündigt, dass das kommen wird, und zwar, die Weep Text to Speech tut jetzt
Und man kann sie direkt auswählen
Man beachte hier mal mein Testbild hier unten, man erkennt es ja vielleicht so ein bisschen
Telekom, am Start
Big Brain, auf jeden Fall
Ja, und dann müssen wir uns noch zusammen ein bisschen was überlegen, wie wir das noch an manchen Stellen ein bisschen verbessern können
Weil, so manche Sachen finde ich nicht so intuitiv, ja
Zum Beispiel hab ich mir überlegt, ob man nicht jetzt noch eine dritte Art von Anime Grills, ja, hab ich auch zu bieten, guck hier
Und da werden wir auch gleich noch was einbauen dafür
Zwar, ähm, eine Sache, es ist ja so, wenn man jetzt, mal genau mal uploadet jetzt was, ne?
Ich zeig euch das mal, mal genau mal uploadet jetzt was hier, das da
Warum ist das Bild kaputt?
Das ist schlecht, ich hab irgendwas kaputt gemacht
Normalerweise sollte da jetzt ein Bild kommen
Ich hab vorhin noch irgendwas kaputt gemacht
Pock
Hm
Was hab ich denn da kaputt gemacht vorhin?
Moment, das müssen wir jetzt gleich, das müssen wir jetzt mal fixen, also beim, beim Bilder, beim Bilderupload ist das kaputt?
What? Warum? Warum ist das beim Bilderupload kaputt?
Man sollte den Krams vorher testen, bevor, bevor man live geht, ha?
Was könnten das sein? Was hab ich denn gemacht vorhin? Warum, warum könnte der Bilderupload kaputt sein?
Was hab ich denn gemacht?
Zeig ich mal hier, reintracken, droppen und dann untersuchen
Ach, der ruft bestimmt von der, von der Ver, wobei ne ist
Ah, ich glaub ich weiß was ich gemacht hab, ich weiß was ich gemacht hab
Ähm, ich hab, ich hab rumgespielt an wie die Form erstellt wird
Irgendwo hier
Moment, hier, hier irgendwo hier hab ich dran rumgespielt vorhin
Da hab ich, da hab ich bestimmt irgendwas kaputt gemacht, ja genau, genau, hier, da
Da, da hab ich, irgendwas hab ich hier geschreckt
Was könnte ich denn hier kaputt gemacht haben?
Machen wir mal schöne Console-Log-Debug-Ausgaben
Gucken ob das funktioniert, was, da hab ich vorhin dran rumgebaut, das weiß ich noch
Das war keine allzu gute Idee
So, gucken wir mal, Konsole
Ah, mal neu laden
Aha, aha, seht ihr das, das wird noch nicht mal aufgerufen
Aha
Da stimmt was nicht
Da stimmt was nicht, wenn das nicht aufgerufen wird, da ist was, äh, fail
Ok, das funktioniert
Name is px, also, das, das geht
Mal mal weiter
Type
Da war noch was, da war noch was, da war noch was, da war noch was
Type, darf man JavaScript vielleicht Sachen nicht Type nennen, kann das sein?
Image-png, ok, das stimmt auch
Da müsste der Regex hier aber matchen, ne?
Benutzt du ReSharper? Nein, nein, mach ich nicht, hab ich früher, hab ich total geschwört auf ReSharper
Aber mittlerweile, finde ich, braucht man es eigentlich nicht mehr
Ja, warum geht das denn nicht?
Ok, gucken wir mal weiter, also dahin gehts schon mal
Und als nächstes sollte eigentlich das da passieren
Machts aber nicht
Weil, mein Regex nicht matcht
Bestimmt, bestimmt hab ich den Regex kaputt gemacht
Darum ist bestimmt noch irgendwie ein Sternchen oder sowas, ok
Der Regex matcht nicht, warum, warum, warum, genau
Image, das ist doch nicht mein Regex, äh, Image, slash, starts with, was, woran genau?
Starts with, was, woran genau stört er sich jetzt?
Bissle Musik, soll ich lauter machen? Ich kanns lauter machen
Ich hab noch die gleichen Settings von gestern drin
Aber ihr wisst ja, dass sich Windows prinzipiell verstellt
Ach, oh man, siehste, warum gibt es da kein Fehler, was ist das für ein Scheiß?
Ich weiß hier drinnen ein Typ, Javascript, please, go on brah
Ja, jetzt funktionierts auch
Oh man, so ne Scheiße, das fällt einem nie auf, ne?
Oh Gott, Javascript, gut
Ja genau, weil das hab ich vorhin auch eingebaut, schonmal zur Vorbereitung, dass man noch mehr Sachen machen können später
Was war der Fehler? Der Fehler war, dass das hier ein Gleichmal anstatt dem Vergleich
Und ich vermute mal, was Javascript in dem Fall macht ist
Also, sag mal so, ne normale Programmiersprache würde mir sagen an der Stelle
Ey guck mal, in deinem if ist nix, was ich auswerten kann, das funktioniert nicht
Javascript aber nicht
Ähm, deswegen vermute ich mal, dass Javascript hier einfach type den String Audiowaff zuweist
Und natürlich Audiowaff match nicht auf Image
Und dementsprechend wird das Bild später auch nicht angezeigt
Was ja fail ist, ich will nämlich eigentlich gucken, ob der Typ gleich Audiowaff ist
Nicht Audiowaff ist
Weil Javascript, ne?
Man weiß es nicht genau
Not a number, not a number
So, wir sehen ja viele Leute da, jetzt zeig ich euch mal beste neue Feature überhaupt
Ich demonstriere es mal
Ich demonstriere es mal anhand dieses Telecom-Bills hier unten
Javascript gibt einen Fehler, also ich hab in die Chrome-Konsole geguckt, da ist nix drin gewesen an Fehler
Guck
Zack
Konsole, irgendwo, sonst was
Was?
Gibt keinen Fehler, macht's einfach nicht
Max, kennst du den JSFuck-Payload?
Was zum Teufel ist ein JSFuck-Payload?
Ist das sowas wie das indische Zeichen, wo man das iPhone mit abkacken lassen kann oder wie?
Okay, Moment Leute, jetzt aber ein neues Feature, muss ich die Musik so ausmachen?
Ich sag mal, die Musik ist ganz schön leise, gell?
Ich glaub, das ist einfach nur ganz besonders ambient gerade
Ähm, ich mach jetzt mal die Musik aus
Jetzt, jetzt, Achtung
Weep Text-to-Speech in Action
Der casht noch linkslokal, deswegen dauert das ein bisschen
Der schickt das jedes Mal zu irgendeinem japanischen Server, lässt Text-to-Speech machen und dann fängt's wieder
Aber es funktioniert prinzipiell schon mal ganz gut
Ja, und man kann das sogar alles auswählen im Web-Interface, ne?
Ja, so ist das
So, und ähm, man kann jetzt mittlerweile jeglichen Text einstellen, man kann die Stimme auswählen
Also, ich zeig's euch mal, das heißt, man kann die Stimme auswählen
Man kann jetzt mittlerweile jeglichen Text einstellen, man kann die Stimme auswählen, also ich zeig's euch mal, das hab ich heute Vormittag eingebaut
Ähm, das wollte ich schon die ganze Zeit einbauen, das haben wir angenommen, hier, man möchte jetzt ein neues Bildchen haben
Das haben wir jetzt schon drinnen, deswegen bietet sich das nicht an
So, und jetzt kann man hier den Mute-Knopf drücken
Und wir haben auch direkt, direkt, äh, Briefview, wie sich das anhört, der Text
So, und wenn ich das entmute und eben, ihr seht auch, wenn ich, ich mach mal den Text ein bisschen länger, äh, EatsAF, EatsPi, was weiß ich, irgendwas
So, und wenn ich jetzt hier anmache, dann spielt er das mit der Default-Stimme ab, aber jetzt passt mal auf, das war auch gar nicht so einfach
Wenn ich jetzt abspielen lasse und Mute drücke, dann geht's auch direkt aus
Zack, in your face, direkt, direkt weg
So, und jetzt können wir hier einschalten
Ähm, willst du das Ganze öffentlich zur Verfügung stellen? Die erste Version ist schon öffentlich auf GitHub
Ähm, aber die ist ziemlich eklig gebastelt, ich hab einfach für mich was zusammengeschustert, weil ich sowas gebraucht hab in der Richtung
Und jetzt machen wir das ein bisschen schöner
So, jetzt kann man nämlich hier die Stimmen auswählen, aktuell gibt's Default-Stimme
Die Default-Stimme ist halt Windows Default, je nachdem auf welcher Sprache man es stehen hat
Easy AF, easy PZ
Easy as fuck, easy PZ
GG noch davor, genau, und ich kann jetzt auch sagen, ich möchte nicht die Default-Stimme, sondern die Weep-Stimme mit dem japanischen Text-to-Speech-Service, wie gesagt, das dauert jetzt ein bisschen, in Zukunft lasse ich das ganze Lokal noch zwischenspeichern, dass er nicht jedes Mal den gleichen Text nach Japan schicken muss, das ist irgendwie bescheuert
Aber es geht jetzt auch schon ein Preview über das Web-Interface
Funktioniert halt mit Japanisch nicht ganz so gut, man muss natürlich gucken, was man da als Text eingibt
Ah, aber wenn wir da jetzt zum Beispiel sowas eingeben
Das kennen wir ja schon, da wissen wir, dass das gut funktioniert
Ja, Kiyokon, ich find's halt trotzdem übelst verwirrend, dass das in JavaScript so ist
Na und mal gucken, was wir noch alles für Sachen einbauen für verschiedene Text-to-Speech-Engines, also aktuell denke ich reicht's mal zwei, Windows Default und halt hier für alle
Für alle Anime-Fans
Vielleicht muss man was ausprobieren
Fast, fast, fast
Klingt gar nicht so schlecht, oder?
Reicht da nicht ein Surface-Worker zum kennen? Nee, ich mach das
Ich krieg ja eh Bites als, also Waff als Bites zurück und die speichere ich einfach im gleichen Ordner, wo ich auch die Bilder speicher
Und guck einfach, ob für jeweilige ALDI was da ist, aber das mach ich dann demnächst noch
Ja, und das ist das nächste worauf wir kommen, mir ist nämlich eingefallen, wir könnten ja eigentlich noch anstatt nur Bilder, Text-to-Speech oder Bilder und Text-to-Speech
Könnten wir eigentlich noch was drittes unterstützen, nämlich nicht Text-to-Speech als Audio, sondern einfach eine Audio-Datei
Also sprich, dass man dann sich ein Bildchen reinziehen kann, plus eine Audio-Datei und das Ganze wird dann zusammen abgespielt
Das ist dann eigentlich im Prinzip ähnlich, wie was man so auf Steamlabs oder so kriegt, wo man Sub-Alerts und sowas machen kann, da hast du ja auch immer irgendein Bild, was du auswählen kannst, plus irgendwie einen vorgefertigten Ton, plus alternativ noch Text-to-Speech
Also das können wir hier im Endeffekt auch machen
Was zum Teufel?
Die Musik ist übelst leise
Ja, ich glaube so ist es ganz okay
Ja, hallo Eiskäuter
Wie lange ist der Halloween Sale? Keine Ahnung, ist es Halloween Sale? Ist mir gar nicht bewusst
Was gibt es denn im Halloween Sale? Müssen wir gleich mal gucken
Ich muss mal Steam ausmachen, dazu muss ich das Display wieder ausschalten, weil ich weiß nicht, was Steam am einen Tag hinfällt
Aber jetzt wird die Musik wieder zu laut
Paladins, Woodface
Ah, hier ist der Halloween Sale
Das habe ich heute Morgen eingebaut
Es fehlen jetzt eigentlich zwei Sachen, damit ich noch einbaue, bevor wir das Ganze raushauen
Und zwar, einmal, dass man auswählen kann, dass man hier nicht Text-to-Speech haben will, sondern dass man eine Custom-MP3-Waffdatei oder so zusätzlich noch hochladen kann
Und was wir natürlich auch noch machen müssen, dass das Favorisieren funktioniert
Ihr seht ja, man kann hier oben favorisieren, das macht aber nichts
Ich habe mir das so gedacht, sprich, wir machen hier nichts, was du von Hand sortieren kannst
Das ist komplizierter, als es letztendlich aussieht auf den ersten Blick
Und gar nicht so einfach
Sondern, wir machen einfach, dass man die wichtigen Dinger favorisieren kann, das sprich, dass alles was favorisiert, steht halt immer vorne
Im Endeffekt, wir machen dann oben noch zwei Buttons hin, wo man ordnen kann, nach Upload-Datum oder so
Und das reicht, ich meine, es wird kaum einer mehr als, sagen wir mal, 50 Dinger oder so da drinnen haben
Genau, und was auch noch eine wichtige Geschichte ist, was wir auf jeden Fall machen müssen
Wir müssen das Programm editierbar machen, also aktuell ist es nämlich so, wenn man in den Edit-Modus von einem Bild geht, passiert
Oh, ein bisschen was passiert zumindest schon
Also so ein bisschen was passiert, wenn man das editiert, aber hier, löschen und so funktioniert alles noch nicht
Löschen, editieren, speichern und so geht noch nicht, sprich, wenn man sich jetzt verschreibt, aktuell beim Upload kann man das nachträglich noch nicht ändern
Das ist ziemlich pünkt, aber das dürfte kein allzu großer Hakt sein, weil ich meine, prinzipiell geht ja alles zu ändern und ist ja auch schon so drinnen
Sagen wir mal, Spack Twitch gerade kann das sein
Bei mir ist gerade die Startseite abgekackt, aber das könnte auch an meinem Browser liegen
Nee, ich glaube das liegt an meinem Browser
Also bei mir ist eben die Startseite abgekackt
Also nicht abgekackt in Form von Crash, sondern dass es halt keine Videos gelaufen haben
Gut, ja und was wir heute mal einbauen, das dürfte relativ simpel sein, deswegen machen wir das on stream
Wir bauen hier mal ein, dass wir quasi Dinge, die wir nicht mehr haben wollen, löschen können
Also wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel irgendwas hochgeladen haben und wir wollen das löschen, das geht ja aktuell nicht, was halt irgendwie doof ist
Und dann muss ich euch noch was, der Tio, stimmt, der Tio ist gerade online gekommen
Was spielt er, Skyrim spielt er, der spielt immer Skyrim
Der Tio spielt den ganzen Tag nichts anderes als Skyrim
Ich muss euch noch was zeigen, Rammverbrauch, ähm, zeig euch das mal, wo ist das hier, das Ding ist übertrieben rammhungrig, aber es sieht nur so aus
Tio, ein Video zu Skyrim gemacht, ok, passt mal auf Rammverbrauch, jetzt haltet euch fest
So hier, Rammverbrauch, Achtung, bam, 500 MP und noch mal auf, zack
Das ist, ohne Garbage Collector Runs ist, dauert das immer so eine Minute oder so bis es wieder weggeht
Und ich hab's vorhin geschafft durch einfach durch Bilder anklicken auf 2GB Rammverbrauch zu kommen für ein paar GIFs
Aber wenn man den Garbage Collector, ja guck, wenn man den öfters laufen lässt an der Stelle, dann geht's, dann ist nicht so dolle
Man sieht auch beim Laden von solchen GIFs, da ist dieses WPF Ding nicht sonderlich schnell
Hier so, klick, pff, dick, pff, also es dauert ewig, gucken ob wir es wieder auf 2, ja komm wir kriegen es auf 2G, jawoll, wir haben es geschafft, 2G, easy
Ja, aber wenn man den Garbage Collector einmal nach Bilderaustauschen, collecten lässt, ich dachte auch, dass der schneller ist
Ich dachte, ich musste vorher noch nie manuell, noch nie, bei nix bisher, den Garbage Collector manuell anwerfen
Allerdings, hier braucht man das irgendwie, na, guck, wenn ich jetzt hier anmache und dann switche, oder auch nicht, switche, da geht's wieder runter
Ah, ich muss von GIF auf GIF switchen, ok, das ergibt irgendwo Sinn
Nein, es ergibt keinen Sinn, was auch immer, aber dann geht's schneller, na, wie man hier sieht
Und ich mein, jetzt sind wir bei ganz guter Rahmenauslastung hier normalerweise, also sprich ich irgendwie bei, was ist denn das
198 MB, da kannst du dich echt nicht beschweren, 198 MB für das ganze ASP.NET Zeug, für ein paar gecashte Bilder
Für die Desktop Anwendung ist das eigentlich schon verdrehtbar, gut, der Browser ist natürlich nicht drauf, aber der Browser sollte ja eigentlich auch gar nicht auf dem Rechner laufen
Ja, wer hat schon weniger als 16 GB Rahmen, genau, brauchen wir nicht, Garbage Collector aus, nie collecten
Was, und die Bilder werden dann über den Stream angezeigt, ja, du siehst sie ja, also ja, offensichtlich, ja
Also die Bilder werden nicht über den Stream angezeigt, die werden bei mir auf dem Desktop angezeigt und ich capture die mit
Man kann die auch nur in OBS einbinden, das funktioniert auch, dass man sie selber nicht sieht, aber eines der Gründe, warum ich das Tool programmiert habe ist, dass ich die Bilder selbst sehe
Ach so ineffizient ist Java eigentlich gar nicht, wenn man es gescheit macht, aber ich bin auch kein Java Fan
Ich hab noch nie freiwillig, also ich hab noch nie was in Java gemacht, weil ich mich, ich konnte mich da bisher immer vordrücken
Memmiyori League, ne, das gibt's nicht, das dachte ich nur, weil der Garbage Collector so langsam war
Dreckspar
Ja klar, aber wie sollen das Streamer schnell verwenden, wenn sie ingame sind, ohne das Spiel zu minimieren
Ja, das ist ja gerade Sinn und Zweck von diesem Tool und zwar, ich muss mal gucken, ob ich hier irgendein Spiel hab, wird man das jetzt gescheit ausprobieren können
Ich brauch irgendein Spiel der letzten 10 Jahre, was im Borderless Window läuft zumindest
Keine Ahnung, irgendwas, komm wir nehmen einfach mal stellvertretend jetzt ein Video für, das machen wir mal in Fullscreen
So, du hast zwei Möglichkeiten, also wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus, dass hier ist dein Fullscreen Spiel, ne
Du hast zwei Möglichkeiten, du kannst entweder, ups, ich sollte das natürlich auch mal starten
Das ist jetzt dein Fullscreen Spiel, dein Borderless Fullscreen Spiel, Borderless Window, also exklusiv Fullscreen geht natürlich nicht
So, dann kannst du Overlay anzeigen lassen
Da spackt zwar der YouTube-Dings hier ein bisschen rum, aber die Games minimieren sich dadurch nicht
Also sprich, du kannst Overlay anzeigen lassen, du hast einmal die Möglichkeit, dir die Bilder auf Shortcuts zu binden
Bei mir ist jetzt hier Steuerung L ist Null, Steuerung M ist Mal ein KS
Oder aber, du machst das Web-Interface auf dem zweiten Monitor oder auf deinem Tablet auf, so ist es nämlich auch gedacht
Und du kannst darüber schalten, also sprich, wenn du jetzt irgendwie 50 Bildchen drinne hast
Und willst halt nicht alles Shortcuts zuweiten, so weil man sich die Shortcuts hier auch gar nicht alle merken kann
Also ich würde mir dann zum Beispiel die meistbenutzten auf Shortcuts legen, Null, Null 3D, Monkeys und so was hier
Und den Papagei und so was, die lege ich mir auf Shortcuts
Und die anderen würde ich dann vom Tablet aus über das Web-Interface anmachen
Also deswegen, dass das Web-Interface hier offen ist, ist ja einfach nur, dass ihr es seht
Ja, das ist ein bisschen wie Elgato Stream Deck, plus ohne Elgato Stream Deck
Und eine Sache, die ich mir schon aufgeschrieben habe, dass wir in Zukunft Elgato Stream Deck Integration machen
Weil ich habe nämlich was gefunden, womit das gehen müsste
Nee, nicht Node
Das da, genau
Weiß ich genau welches war, ich glaube das hier
Nee, das hier, das mit den Sternen
Da hat nämlich jemand schon einen.NET Rapper programmiert für Stream Deck
Das heißt, da können wir probieren das Ganze noch einzubauen
Also sprich, dann könnte man nämlich nicht nur von seinem Tablet ausdrücken und die Bildchen anmachen, sondern auch von Steam Deck
Und was natürlich immer geht, ist Shortcut vom Streaming-PC hier, auf und zu
Ja, aber was wir wie gesagt noch einbauen, ist einmal, dass man normale Audio-Files verwenden kann und nicht nur Text-to-Speech
Und dass man die Kram editieren kann, und dass man die Kram editieren kann, machen wir jetzt
Zum Beispiel das hier löschen, ihr seht ja, tut sich noch nichts
Tut sich nichts, das habe ich jetzt gemacht
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man das, wie habe ich denn das hingekriegt?
Das muss ich noch mal gucken
Wie habe ich das Drag und Drop eben hingekriegt?
Ach, was auch immer
Genau, so weit dazu
Also, wie du siehst, ich weiß nicht, wer es gefragt hat
Ich glaube der MoonEaterBaku hat es gefragt
Das reißt dich nicht aus dem Fullscreen raus
Sofern das Spiel Borderless Window Fullscreen oder wie das heißt unterstützt
Was mittlerweile Standard ist und was eigentlich jedes Spiel der letzten 10 Jahre kann
Exklusiv Fullscreen, wie bei alten Source-Games zum Beispiel oder so, ist ein bisschen schwieriger
Da müsste man sich DinoX-mäßig reinhängen und dann schlagen wir da irgendwelche Anti-Cheatinger an oder so, das wollen wir nicht
Auf der anderen Seite kann man ja auch die meisten Fullscreen-Games mit einem zusätzlichen Tool oder so
Borderless Window machen und das heißt es geht eh
Wie teuer wird das Programm sein? Das wird kostenlos sein
Wie gesagt, die erste Version gibt es ja schon auf GitHub, die kann aber noch nicht wirklich was
Und die zweite wird es auch kostenlos geben mit einem gescheiten
Ich will es nicht Installer nennen, weil es wird kein Installer in Form von weiter, weiter, weiter Admin-Rechte
Sondern einfach eine einzelne Exe, die man ausführen kann, dass es quasi installiert und ab und zu mal nach Updates guckt
Da habe ich keinen Bock sowas selbst zu machen
Was macht man damit? Ja, ich habe es gerade, ich weiß nicht, ob du es noch gesehen hast, ich habe es gerade gezeigt
Wir müssen mal ein Spiel installieren
Wir müssen mal ein Spiel installieren, was man Fullscreen machen kann
Oder Cort, wir machen das neue Cort mal an, falls ich noch installiert habe
Da muss ich mal kurz Battle.net anmachen und das Battle.net muss ich mal wieder ausmachen hier, dass ihr was seht
Overwatch, in Overwatch funktioniert es, das haben wir schon ausprobiert
Ihh, Achtung jetzt lag der Stream klar
Kann man das irgendwie, was? Waiting, Update
Updating Battle.net
Das Zeug, was ich immer alles drei Stunden updaten muss
Ja, Restart, ich habe nämlich gesehen, dass ich die richtige E-Mail Adresse eingetragen habe, die die auch bei YouTube auf dem Channel steht
So, Moment, wie macht man das? Pause, sonst lag der Stream
Wie macht man das, wie macht man das, das ist weniger
Update, installen, download, ah hier!
Patch-Starter, Latest Updates, okay das, ey Tastatur
War das eine Null zu viel?
Eigentlich nicht. Ah doch es war eine Null zu viel, aber jetzt sollte das Ganze nicht ruckeln
Spiel mal Blackout, ich habe schon Blackout gespielt
Ah doch, das war dann null zu viel.
Aber jetzt okay, jetzt sollte das ganze nicht ruckeln.
Spiel mal Blackout.
Ich hab schon Blackout gespielt.
In der Beta.
Ich bin halt einfach kein Battle-Battle-Royale-Typ irgendwie.
Ja.
Wir machen jetzt mal das Black Ops Update,
dass man...
dass ich das mal im Spiel zeigen kann, was das eigentlich macht.
Ich hab's den Black Ops noch nie ausprobiert, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich hab's noch nie ausprobiert, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber wie gesagt, es sollte in jedem Game direkt instant funktionieren,
was Borderless Fullscreen unterstützt
und was keine, und das ist das Wichtige,
das macht aber kaum einer, das macht noch nicht mal mehr LoL mittlerweile, glaube ich,
was keine Tastatureingaben frisst.
Also sprich, wenn das irgendwelche Low-Level-Tastatur-Hooks drin hat,
dass die Tastendrücke erst gar nicht mehr an Windows ankommen,
dann kann es natürlich auch keine Shortcuts erkennen, logischerweise.
Aber dann kann man es immer noch vom Tablet aus fernsteuern.
Das muss ich gerade mal übrigens wieder einbauen,
weil das hab ich vorhin rausgenommen,
dass man vom anderen Rechner drauf zugreifen kann.
Ich mach mal gucken, wie ich das gemacht hab.
Ja, so, da.
So hab ich das gemacht.
Äh, zu viele Punkte?
Nope.
Hatte jemand mal einen Multisreddit?
Ja.
Hatte jemand mal einen Multisreddit-UDP-Server auf Python programmiert?
Nein.
Was hast du denn vor?
Kannst du mal erzähl...
Also, erzähl mal was du vor hast.
Ich mein, ich würde eh versuchen,
Abstand davon zu halten, wenn es nicht anders geht.
Ja, manchmal geht es halt nicht anders.
Selbst irgendwelche TCP, UDP, Socket-Geschichten und sowas
noch selbst zu machen.
Ja, Milch, mir fällt auch nichts ein, wo das so ist.
Die ollen Games können halt manchmal keinen Fullscreen,
also kein Windows-Fullscreen.
Bei manchen funktioniert es doch.
Mit ein bisschen Trick.
Man kann nämlich anstatt das Fenster, das Overlay-Fenster zu minimieren und zu maximieren,
kann man einfach ein transparentes PNG-Overlayen,
dass das Fenster sich nicht ändert.
Dann geht das bei manchen.
Aber in der Regel funktioniert es nicht.
Und da muss man gucken, dass man die Games dann halt ins borderless,
ins borderless Fullscreen-Window versetzt.
Dafür gibt es Tools.
Da macht man nämlich einfach in-Game-Window-Mode an
und dann mit einem externen Tool sagt man Fullscreen-Window.
Dann geht es eh.
So, während das runter lädt, können wir uns ja mal den Steam-Cell angucken,
ob da irgendetwas Gescheites drin ist.
Was haben wir denn hier im Halloween-Sale?
Top Sellers.
Dead by Daylight.
Das soll ganz nice sein.
Ist auch meistens positiv.
Darkest Dungeon ist sehr nice.
Richtig geiles Game.
Ja, also es ist sehr, sehr schön.
Ja, Ice-Kreuter, mir fällt kein neueres ein.
Also wenn du halt alte Source-Games spielst.
Zum Beispiel, im letzten Steam haben wir Dark Messiah auf My Magic gespielt.
Das konnte das nicht.
Da habe ich dann die Funktion genommen, dass es nur in OBS angezeigt wird.
Das habe ich auch schon eingebaut, das geht ja.
Man hat immer eine Möglichkeit, das zu verwenden.
Jetzt wird auch noch gesungen.
Ja, was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen?
Also man hat immer die Möglichkeit, im Endeffekt das zu verwenden.
Selbst wenn das Spiel nur Wind-Out-Mode unterstützt,
gibt es hier, ich weiß nicht, wie hieß das, Borderless Gaming?
Das da?
Ich glaube, das ist es.
Ja, das ist es.
Damit kann man quasi jedes Game in Borderless Vollscreen versetzen, was Wind-Out-Mode kann.
Also man kann es eigentlich immer verwenden.
So, was haben wir sonst noch hier zu bieten?
Da war der erste Teil, den zweiten kenne ich nicht.
Das ist so Left 4 Dead-Style im Warhammer-Universum.
Hardstone habe ich ja, aber habe ich eben noch mal gespielt.
Borderless Window ist die Performance nicht so gut.
Da ist überhaupt kein großer Unterschied dazwischen.
Das Einzige, was du theoretisch hast, ist minimal höhere Input-Lag,
weil es nicht direkt in den Grafikkarten-RAM reinschreiben kann,
sondern durch den Window-Manager durch muss.
Das sind aber auch nur ein paar Minisekunden.
Und dass die Performance unterschiedlich ist, würde ich sagen,
nicht im großartig messbaren Bereich.
Vielleicht, weil man eh schon gerade an der Grenze von 30 FPS ist und gerade so spielen kann.
Und man dann quasi mit dem einen hat man 32, mit dem anderen 28.
Aber wenn du das Game eh mit 144 FPS hast,
du merkst keinen Unterschied mittlerweile nicht mehr zwischen Window-Mode oder mit Fullscreen.
Außerdem geht es jetzt ja im Prinzip auch nicht großartig um Competitive-Weekly-Cups-Turniere oder sonst was.
Es geht um Leute, die streamen und spielen.
Und man kann auch im Borderless Window Competitive spielen.
Also in der Zeit, wo ich Overwatch Competitive gespielt habe,
habe ich fast immer außer sonntags im Cup immer Borderless Window gespielt.
Oh, das ist aber abgedreht, Promis, das was ihr davor habt.
Kumpel will mit einem Auto rumfahren, das über einen Raspberry Pi angeschlossen ist.
Den UDP-Server brauchen wir für den Controller, der dann über das interne Netzwerk des Autos steuert.
What?
Beziehungsweise Controller wird an einem Laptop angeschlossen,
schickt die String-Data an einen Raspberry auf dem Auto, spielt Sounds ab und oder...
Moment, ihr wollt euer Auto Remote steuern?
Sehen wir von einem Auto, von einem richtigen Auto oder von einem Modell-Auto?
Also wenn du irgendwie dann echt das Auto fernsteuern willst, dann würde ich das sein lassen.
Das ist harter Bonkers, das würde ich nicht machen.
Wo ist überhaupt der Unterschied zwischen Borderless Window und Fullscreen?
Fullscreen kann im Prinzip das Game direkt in den Grafikram schreiben.
Und wenn du ein Window hast, muss es einmal durch den Window-Manager durch,
weil es könnte sein, dass es überlagert ist von einem anderen Fenster in ein anderes Fenster.
Composite-Manager, also der, der halt hier dafür sorgt, dass hier Fenster Overlayed sind,
Fenster Schatten-Effekte haben und solche Dinge.
Da muss es einmal durch, aber nein, das geht ja schnell.
Das heißt, wenn du 144Hz hast, das können maximal irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
6-7 Millisekunden, wenn überhaupt, wenn überhaupt sein, wenn überhaupt.
Das sind wahrscheinlich sogar noch ganze Ecke weniger.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, es wird keiner merken mit ordentlich FPS-Anzahl.
Warum hast du so einen Namen bei Twitch?
Weil das erstmal ein ursprünglicher Account war, mit dem ich eigentlich gar nicht selbst streamen wollte.
Mornin' Serious Max.
Ab welcher Viewerzahl bietet Twitch andere Auflesungen an?
Das ist egal.
Das wird entschieden, wenn du live gehst.
Also wenn du nicht Twitch, also wenn du Twitch-Partner bist, hast du Prioritäten, hast du das im Prinzip immer.
Wenn du Affiliate bist, hast du auch höhere Prioritäten und kriegst das auch meistens.
Und wenn du weder das eine noch das andere bist, dann musst du Glück haben,
dass beim Starten deines Streams genug Kapazitäten frei sind.
Deswegen mache ich manchmal den Stream auch einfach 2-3 Mal an und aus.
Und dann haben wir Qualitätsoptionen.
Ich könnte aber auch einfach mal entweder Twitch-Partner oder Affiliate machen demnächst.
Ja MrMilch, man denke ich auch, das ist wahrscheinlich saumäßig kurz.
Theoretisch hättest du halt irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, wie lang braucht du ein Bild bei 144Hz?
7 Millisekunden oder so.
7 Millisekunden?
Oder?
1000 Millisekunden eine Sekunde?
6,9 Millisekunden pro Bild bei 145Hz?
Oder ist QuickMuffs gerade nicht so angesagt?
Stimmt?
QuickMuffs.
Bist du kein Aufwärtschneider aktuell nicht?
Ach, kein echtes Auto, Spielzeugauto, was eh mit Kontrollerspiel war.
Also, wie gesagt, ich würde keinen UDP-Server von Hand basteln.
Sondern ich würde irgendwas Fertiges nehmen.
Also irgendeine Message-Q-Technologie, Zero-MQ-Signal-R.
Vielleicht auch das ganze über HTTP machen.
Ich meine mittlerweile ist das ja kein Ding mehr.
Da kannst du demnächst sicher sein, dass auch alles ankommt.
Du kannst ordentliche Antworten hinschicken.
Du musst dich nicht um jeden scheiß Helm kümmern.
Also ich kann dir empfehlen, machs über HTTP, da hast du nämlich viele Probleme nicht.
Und dann über irgendeine Message-Q das ganze machen.
Dass es auf jeden Fall ankommt und ordentlich bearbeitet wird.
Und das ist ja schon Multithreaded.
Also sprich, wenn du sowas wie ASP.NET Core nimmst, da ist ja jeder Request ein eigener Thread.
Muss ja, sonst wird das ja überhaupt nicht scaling.
Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass ihr wirklich die Performance braucht,
es quasi Raw-UDP von Hand zu machen im Vergleich zu einem ordentlich optimierten HTTP-Server.
Also ich muss sagen, seitdem ich hier mit Signal-R was gemacht hab für das Web-Interface hier.
Wird das da?
Ich mein, man sieht es ja im Endeffekt.
Und ich versuch's mal zu zeigen.
Also sprich, das geht hier über Signal-R rüber.
Also sprich, wenn ich Shortcut drücke, ist die Markierung im Web-Interface.
Geht einmal über den Web-Server drüber, per Signal-R an den Browser-Client.
So, und jetzt lass ich das mal ausblenden.
Ihr seht im Prinzip, da ist keine Verzögerung dazwischen.
Das ist wirklich, ich mein, das ist jetzt auch lokal, ja, aber das ist instant.
Das ist absolut instant.
Auch das Draufklicken hier, da ist kein Lack oder sonst was.
Machst das Bild an, zack.
Das Einzige, wo es ein bisschen länger hängt, ist wenn die Bilder groß sind, weil das Ding ist 4K.
4K MonkaS braucht ein bisschen beim ersten Mal Laden.
Wenn er gecached ist, geht er auch schnell.
Ja, oder so komische grottenschlechterstellte GIFs wie das hier.
Das dauert auch ein bisschen.
Aber das liegt nicht an der Übertragung, sondern einfach, dass die Desktop-App so lange braucht, bis das Bild geladen hat.
Warum hab ich nur jemanden zugesagt, bei einer WordPress-Seite das Frontends zu customisern?
Wahrscheinlich, weil du gute Frontends designen kannst.
Ja, hallo Dudelsack94.
Der Stream ist definitiv nicht für jeden, aber ich mach das öfters.
Das ist ja schon irgendwie der, keine Ahnung, 50. Stream, wo wir Zeug zusammen programmieren.
So, also.
Jetzt basteln wir uns, jetzt müssen wir mal hier weitermachen.
So, wie gesagt, eine wichtige Sache, die ich eigentlich vorher noch einbauen wollte, aber gedacht hab, das können wir jetzt auch an Stream machen, ist, dass man Sachen löschen kann.
Aktuell kann man nur Sachen hinzufügen.
Also aktuell kann man nur Sachen reintracken, droppen, Zeugseinstellen, uploaden, drücken.
Und was wir jetzt machen müssen ist, also zum Beispiel, den hab ich jetzt doppelt abgeloadet hier.
Ihn hier.
WTF, was los?
What?
Und den hier will ich löschen.
Ich hab das jetzt aktuell so eingestellt, dass wenn man die mittlere Maustaste drauf drückt, das ist ein total bescheuerter Shortcut, ja.
Bescheuerte Taste, da kommt kein Mensch drauf, ja.
Da muss man irgendwas anderes einfallen lassen.
Geht hier das Menü zum löschen auf.
Beziehungsweise, nee, das Menü zum editieren geht auf.
Da könnte man neuen Hotkey festlegen.
Oder Text-to-Speech einschalten.
Oder sein lassen.
Da kann man speichern drücken oder löschen drücken.
Die Sache ist die, das geht sauber seitlich noch nicht.
Das muss man jetzt mal einbauen.
Dass man zumindest Sachen, die man doppelt hat löschen kann und im nächsten Schritt Sachen, die man schon hochgeladen hat, editieren kann.
Weil alles andere ist blöd.
Sollte kein allzu großer Akt sein, weil im Prinzip geht's ja schon.
Halt bloß nicht über Sub-Interface.
Max, deine Meinung zu World War 3?
Ich hab's immer noch nicht gespielt.
Ich hab's seit Release...
Wir wollten ein Release mal spielen und da waren die sauber dauernd.
Ich wollte aber mal gucken.
Steam Stats.
Nee.
Was ist denn?
Steam Stats.
Okay, so war Steam Stats Pupke.
Funktioniert, tauschen einfach die App-ID aus.
Das hast du letztes Mal auch so gemacht.
Ja.
Also das Spiel muss gar nicht so schlecht sein.
Weil die Spieler sind relativ konstant.
Was bei Early Access Sachen nicht so der Fall ist.
Normalerweise.
Guckt euch mal im Vergleich hier den hier an.
Das ist so das Negativbeispiel schlechthin.
Die haben es halt einfach mal extrem.
Sowas hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Die haben es so krass extrem ultra verschissen.
Das geht gar nicht.
So zu verscheißen wie die.
Also die haben es einfach so übertrieben verschissen.
Das ist nicht möglich eigentlich.
Guckst du das mal an.
Die hatten mal angefangen mit 104.000 Peak-Player.
Und hatten einen Monat später nur noch 23.000.
Und jetzt haben sie nur noch 2.000.
Richtig Fail.
Mega Fail.
Also Omega Fail sozusagen.
Also das ist verkackt.
Deswegen.
Man sieht bei dem Game, dass das prinzipiell eigentlich ganz gut ankommt.
Das hat hier Early Access gestartet.
Die haben die ersten zwei Tage mal relativ.
Die meisten gespielt, ist auch klar.
Aber danach jeden Tag.
Ungefähr.
Jeden Tag.
So das gleiche.
Also.
Easy.
Ja, ist so richtig.
Rainbow Isle hat es auch spielerisch verkackt.
Richtig.
Das ist ja auch der Grund dafür, dass keiner was spielen will.
Komische Patches.
So.
Jetzt müssen wir mal einbauen.
Dass wir.
Wo ist denn?
Ja.
Jetzt müssen wir mal einbauen.
Bin ich eigentlich schon an der richtigen Stelle.
Das für Zeug.
What the fuck was ist das?
Wie macht man das überhaupt?
Wie macht man das?
Weiß gar nicht, weil die Tasticht dazu drücken muss.
Tasticht.
Wie habe ich das jetzt hingekriegt?
Was auch immer.
So, also wir wollen, wenn man.
Auf den löschen Button klickt.
Dann wollen wir das aktuelle Item löschen.
Also.
Also sprich.
Wenn man das hier anklickt.
Und ich hier auf löschen gehe.
Dann soll das hier verschwinden.
Das ist wichtig und das testen wir mit ihm hier mal.
Wir haben nämlich doppelt drinnen.
Also.
So, also klick.
Delete item.
Boah.
Fällt mir jetzt kein besserer Name für ein.
Mal mal ganz unten hin.
Ah, Alter.
Visual Studio spackt immer so rum.
Mit den Eindrückungen.
Ich kriege Anfälle in Visual Studio damit.
Delete item.
Guck dir jetzt, wie das hier rumjumpt.
Nichts.
Nichts auf Fail.
Delete item.
Da müssen wir eigentlich nur an den Server einen Request schicken.
An das Backend.
Das zu löschen.
Äh.
Zwar ist es ein Delete Request.
Für.
Das Item.
Mit der ID.
Ähm.
Popup Form ID.
Und dann soll das löschen.
Form Data brauchen wir nicht.
So, soweit so gut.
Von der Idee her.
Visual Studio ist die beste Idee, als ich auch so.
Beste.
Wie findest du C++?
Ich habe es in der Berufsschule.
Fachinformatiker, Systemintegration.
Ich finde zum Einstieg ist C++
eines der schlechtesten Ideen, die man so haben kann.
Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum an vielen Berufsschulen
teilweise noch mit C angefangen wird.
Das ist einfach nicht.
Das begeistert keinen fürs Programmieren letztendlich.
Wenn man das später mal braucht
und manche Sachen damit machen muss
oder will.
Wenn man sich dafür entscheidet und sagt,
das will ich jetzt mit C machen.
Aber die Leute quasi mit C am Anfang quälen.
Da hat doch kein Mensch mehr Bock, irgendwas zu programmieren.
C++ an sich
ist nicht schlecht.
Es ist halt unendlich kompliziert.
Was die ganzen Eigenheiten angeht.
Ich glaube es gibt keinen, der
alle C++ Eigenheiten
im Kopf hat.
Die Leute, die in diesem komischen
C++ Board oder wie das heißt hocken.
Es ist auch nicht schön, finde ich.
Natürlich, wenn es um Spiele
programmieren geht und wenn es letztendlich um
reine Performance geht,
dann führt an C++ relativ wenig vorbei.
Aber zum Einsteigen, finde ich, ist das nichts.
Hey Max, ich mache momentan eine
Ausbildung
zum Entwicklern bei einer digitalen
Agentur, die sich auf Frontend spezialisiert.
Ich bin jetzt im zweiten Lehrjahr
und habe realisiert, dass Frontend
nichts für mich ist.
Und ich liebe, wenn es geht,
Volltime Backend machen würde.
Welche Backendsprache könntest du mir
empfehlen, wohne auch in der Umgebung von Frankfurt?
Ich glaube, was man sich...
Also ich würde die Ausbildung nicht wechseln,
deswegen, wenn ich da was an sich Gutes habe.
Das würde ich auf keinen Fall machen.
Weil ich meine,
selbst wenn eine Firma nur
Frontend macht, ich meine,
wo läuft denn das Backend?
Nicht bei euch
dann, oder wie?
Oh Gott, Visual Studio fuck mich nicht ab, ey.
Ja, aber Backendsprache
kommt drauf an. Windows, Linux,
Mac?
Sag mal so, Windows, Linux. Ich gehe mal davon aus, hauptsächlich
Linux. Also zumindest
von Linux kommst du heutzutage nicht mehr rum,
wenn es um Serverbackends geht
oder um Server allgemein geht.
Und ich finde,
nachdem ich mich für dieses Programm
mit dem neuen ASP.NET Core beschäftigt habe,
muss ich sagen, das Gesamtpaket
ist für mich immer noch
.NET und C-Sharp, also.NET Core
jetzt halt neuerdings, und C-Sharp
das beste, was es gibt,
das universellste im Prinzip,
was es gibt.
Also, da kannst du Server
Backends Zeug machen, Commando Zeug machen,
Windows GUI Zeug machen, was halt
mit was anderem nicht gescheit geht,
in beschränkte Maßen Grossplattform GUI
Zeug machen, das finden wir in Zukunft hoffentlich noch besser.
Alternativ natürlich,
wenn es um solche Sachen geht,
natürlich Go und Node.
Wenn es halt um Web,
also Backends
für Web-Geschichten
geht, dann muss man natürlich
Go und Node auch noch erwähnen. Also im Prinzip
passt da eigentlich so die drei Sachen
und meinetwegen Java, aber da hätte ich jetzt
das empfehle ich keinen.
Viele Leute machen auch in Python was,
also die vier Sachen würde ich eigentlich sagen.
Also wenn es um
Backend-Entwicklung geht
für
Web-Geschichten,
dann würde ich sagen, was sich auf jeden Fall lohnt,
ist wenn du Python kannst, so mit Django oder so was,
das ist auch relativ angesagt.
C-Sharp
und ASP.NET Core
Go und Node.
Node muss du dir da passend
Frameworks angucken, was es da so gibt, da kenne ich mich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig aus.
So, jetzt schicken wir an den Server
schon mal die Aufforderung, dass wir doch bitte
dieses Bildchen
löschen. Da müssen wir jetzt mal in
Controller gucken, ob wir hier überhaupt schon eine Methode
haben, wo das ankommt.
Ja, haben wir, aber die macht nichts anderes als OK
zu senden. Das ist natürlich auch ganz dolle.
Wir gucken mal, ob der Aufruf
prinzipiell funktioniert. Wir schalten mal den Debugger
ein
und gucken,
wenn ich auf das Knöpfchen drücke,
ob ich denn dann auch da rauskomme.
Dann sehen wir nämlich, ob das prinzipiell schon mal
funktioniert. Oh.
Ich habe mein JavaScript
kaputt gemacht.
Ah.
Lull.
Ja, das ist logisch.
Das wäre so ganz nicht scharf so gewesen.
So, gucken wir mal,
was passiert, wenn wir auf löschen drücken.
Ja, wir kommen schon mal in dem
in der richtigen Methode
auf unserem Controller raus.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Das ist schon mal gut. So, jetzt können wir das Ganze
löschen. Also, wir müssen löschen,
wir müssen einmal in der Datenbank
den Eintrag löschen und wir müssen
das Bildchen feil löschen, weil sonst
haben wir irgendwann 50.000 Bilder
und die eigentlichen
Sachen dazu schon gelöscht.
Äh,
Akena schreibt, bei ihm an der Uni
lernen sie auch C als einzigesprachlich.
Ich meine, man kann sagen, im Bereich
Elektrotechnik, wenn es um irgendwelche
Kontrollen an Sachen geht, es ist
nicht schlecht, sie haben aber ein bisschen Ahnung
von C, aber
zum Einsteigen
finde ich es halt nicht gut.
Weil, mit C kannst du dir
halt selbst ziemlich in den Fuß schießen
und die Fehlermeldungen
sind auch nicht irgendwie großartig klar.
Es gibt eigentlich keine Fehlermeldungen, außer, dass du
halt versuchst auf Speicherbereiche
zuzugreifen, wo du dich darfst. Das ist die einzige
Fehlermeldung, die es in C gibt.
Und die ist doch nicht mal von C selbst,
sondern, was das Betriebssystem sagt.
Nee, nee, da darfst du nicht hin.
Also, im Prinzip,
in C gibt es eigentlich keine Fehlermeldungen
in dem Sinne. Keine Runtime-Fehlermeldungen.
Ich hatte in der Fach-Oberschule
und jetzt in der Berufsschule Java.
Ja, wenn man
nicht drumherum kommt.
Wir müssen das Assembler. Ihr macht ernsthaft doch Assembler.
Also, wenn ich, ich sage euch ganz ehrlich,
wenn ich die Auswahl hätte,
ähm,
quasi, wenn ich jetzt,
wenn ich mich jetzt entscheiden müsste, was, was,
äh, was lerne ich?
Man kann es zwar nicht so richtig vergleichen,
aber ich finde, dass es
gar nicht schlecht ist,
wenn man ein bisschen Assembler kann.
Ich finde, damit kann man allgemein relativ gut was anfangen.
Entweder, wenn man
halt mal wirklich
ganz im Detail was machen muss.
Weil, so,
so kompliziert
das Assembler auch auf den ersten Blick anmuten muss.
Oder anmutet.
Allein schon, weil man halt jeden Scheiß selbst machen muss.
Ja, da gibt es nichts, da gibt es keine Schleife
automatisch oder sowas.
Ist es einfach so,
dass Assembler an sich
aus einem Grund nicht kompliziert ist.
Und zwar, dass du ganz genau siehst,
was passiert. Weil
es passiert absolut keine Magic
im Hintergrund.
Also sprich, wenn du es gut
durchdacht hast,
funktioniert das auch.
Bis auf die Sachen,
die du nicht durchdacht hast. Und das werden einige sein.
Aber das ist gar nicht so übel.
Okay, also wir müssen
den Kram aus der DB löschen, wir müssen das File
löschen. Das bedeutet,
so,
wir müssen jetzt erstmal das
Meme aus der Datenbank holen.
Dazu sagen wir, das Kontext
übrigens,
mal so,
für die Leute, die neu in ASP.NET Core sind,
ist allen
klar, die es interessiert,
wohlgemerkt. Ja, ich habe jetzt ja schon öfters
gelesen, dass auch einige Leute einfach zugucken, weil es
allgemein interessiert. Aber für die Leute, die sich mit
ASP.NET Core befassen und interessiert,
ist euch klar, wie ich
überhaupt an dieser Stelle
den Kontext habe, um auf die Datenbank
zuzugreifen. Also wo der herkommt.
Dass ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel sagen kann,
find und dann
mit der ID, die ich kriege.
Ich bin mit dem Chat ganz schön hinten dran,
fällt mir gerade auf.
Bist du noch der Systemer
oder bist du mehr oder weniger in der Anwendungsentwicklung gegangen?
Eigentlich ist das ziemlich genau
in der Mitte. Ich kümmere mich
auf der Arbeit um unsere Softwareverwaltung.
Also um unsere
Sourcecodeverwaltung.
Und um den Release von neuen Versionen
von unserer
Pakete von unserer Software.
Und von unserer Sauberkonfiguration.
Besser gesagt.
Das ist so in der
Mitte eigentlich.
Which browser are you using?
Chromium?
Chrome and
Firefox.
And sometimes Edge.
Edge in 2K18 lol.
Hallo Tommy K.
So. Also
das ist nämlich so,
wenn ihr auch mal quasi in
ASP.NET Core was machen wollt.
Und dass man von dem Controller
oder die Request
reinkommen vom Frontend.
Dass man dort was in der Datenbank machen muss,
ist eigentlich Standard. Das ist eigentlich in jeder
Controller Methode so. Man muss sich entweder
die Sachen aus der Datenbank holen um damit was zu machen
oder sie letztendlich schreiben oder irgendwie manipulieren
und in ASP.NET Core
haben sie das so gemacht, wenn du
wenn du einen Controller anlegst,
dann kannst du die hier oben im
Konstruktor kannst du sagen, ich möchte
einen DB Kontext haben.
Und mit diesem DB Kontext kann ich dann
quasi Sachen aus der Datenbank
lesen, in die Datenbank schreiben,
ändern und gedöns.
Und ich muss nichts
selber machen im Prinzip. Ich muss einfach nur
im Konstruktor sagen, ich hätte gerne einen DB Kontext.
Ok, das funktioniert
prinzipiell nur, weil ich am Anfang gesagt habe,
Hallo Anwendung, verwende
diesen DB Kontext
und als Datenbank SQLite.
Aber ich muss nicht,
das ist tatsächlich sehr praktisch,
ich muss hier nichts
machen. Ich kann einfach nur sagen
Gift DB Kontext.
Und dann habe ich einen. Und dann kann ich hier
unten drin sagen, jetzt suchen wir mal
aus der Meme Collection
das mit der ID,
die wir übergeben und dann löschen wir
das Ganze. Wobei so einfach ist das Ganze
nicht.
So, dann kann ich nämlich sagen,
es ist nicht Delete, es ist Remove.
Remove.
Aber ich kann gleich sagen, so einfach ist es
leider nicht, weil
wir haben ja noch auf dem Filesystem
Zeugs. Wenn man sich das hier anguckt,
da haben wir ja hier drin unter
Content, haben wir ja die ganzen Bildchen,
die ich bisher schon hochgeladen habe.
Ohne, dass ich
was gelöscht habe.
Und ungefähr so sieht das aus.
Ungefähr so sieht das aus,
wenn man eben die Sachen
nicht löscht.
Beim Löschen im Frontend.
Ich habe einfach immer die Datenbank
weggeschmissen. Und da sind die Bilder
natürlich dageblieben. Und genauso sollte es ja nicht
aussehen. Also sprich, wenn ich
ein Bild lösche, dann sollte er nicht nur das Bild aus der
Datenbank löschen, sondern da soll auch gefälligst
aus dem Content-Ordner das Bild
löschen. Weil sonst habe ich hier drin irgendwann mal
800 Bilder. Und guck mal, sind jetzt schon
60 MB. Wenn ich das Programm mal
irgendwie ein, zwei Jahre verwendet habe, habe ich ja
wahrscheinlich ein halbes Gigabyte oder so an ungenutzten
Bildern da drin liegen. Das heißt,
das Ganze muss
nicht aus der Datenbank gelöscht werden,
sondern vom File Distribution.
Und für Recording-Videos
benutze ich
ein Bluer
Yeti
Mikrofon.
Das USB
kann man
anklicken und
sofort benutzen.
Eats IF.
Yano-Skiller, so könnte man das auch machen.
So könnte man das auch machen.
Da würde ich sagen, man macht
sich so im Hintergrund so einen
Clean-Job, der halt läuft beim Starten.
Aber es wäre natürlich schon schön, wenn
beim Löschen jetzt auch direkt das
File mitgelöscht wird.
So, und deswegen müssen wir sagen, bevor wir das Ganze
aus der Datenbank löschen,
dann müssen wir das Ganze
direkt aus der Datenbank löschen,
dann müssen wir das Ganze direkt aus der Datenbank löschen,
ja, übrigens,
wenn ihr diesen DB-Kontext
verwendet, um was zu machen,
das wird nicht instant gemacht.
Also man muss immer am Ende sagen
save.
Man muss immer sagen, am Ende save.
Das heißt, alles, was ich hier dazwischen mache,
wird hier erst wirklich ausgeführt.
Und intern auch mal ein bisschen optimiert vorher,
dass er nicht
50 Request an die Datenbank macht.
50 Queries an die Datenbank macht,
da optimiert die dann ein bisschen.
Hat sich deine Meinung über Gaming
hättest du mittlerweile geändert?
Nö, prinzipiell nicht.
Es gibt mittlerweile ein paar gute,
also aber ein paar bessere,
die man empfehlen kann neben dem
MMX300. Das MMX300 fand ich ja schon
immer empfehlenswert.
Aber es gibt mittlerweile ein paar andere. Es gibt von Zenheiser
ein paar gute, es gibt von Cupid ein paar gute.
Was immer, was immer sehr nice ist,
allerdings preisleistungsmäßig auch nicht so der Wahnsinn,
aber auf jeden Fall empfehlenswert ist
das ModMic.
Da sind die jetzt mittlerweile beim
Fünfer, das Fünfer hab ich
noch nicht ausprobiert, nur das Vierer.
Genau, nur das Dreier und das Vierer.
Allerdings werden die Dinger
immer teurer.
Deswegen, ich mein,
ernsthaft, es kann doch nicht sein,
dass die 80 Euro für so ein Mikrofon haben wollen.
Das Dreier hat irgendwie noch damals,
ich weiß nicht, was ich dafür bezahlt hab, irgendwie
35 Euro oder so.
Das Alte kostet auch noch 46,
also es ist viel zu teuer, aber
es ist nicht schlecht.
Wenn man nämlich einen guten Kopfhörer
hat, kann man damit im Endeffekt
jedes, da hab ich übrigens mal ein Video
zugemacht.
Ja, genau, da sieht man es.
Guck, da hab ich hier
mein AKG und mein, weiß gar nicht,
was das hier für einer war.
Den benutze ich nicht mehr, den benutze ich ab und zu
noch zum Musik hören, hauptsächlich.
Das ist ein AKG K701.
Das ist das MMX300.
Und...
Das ist das ModMic, das macht man eben dran.
Irgendwo sieht man es auch.
Ah, hier ist es dran jetzt.
Genau, da sieht man es.
Also das ist eine ganz gute Sache, wenn man schon
ein gutes...
What about Hypercloud 2?
Never used it.
I don't know.
Hatst du jemals Probleme mit dem Kopfband
vom K701? Ja.
Das drückt auf dem Kopf, das ist
ziemlicher Mist.
Deswegen hab ich da so ein bisschen
hässlichen Schaumstoff drunter.
Aber ich muss sagen, also
rein vom Audio,
also wie sich
das Sound anhört, finde ich es besser
als das K701.
Das ist ein K701.
Wie sich das anhört, finde ich
es besser als das MMX300.
Das MMX300 ist ja im Prinzip
ein DT770.
Relativ Badewannen mäßig.
Und das K701
hat einen ziemlich
neutralen Klang, den finde ich eigentlich recht schön.
Aber das Band ist wirklich nervig.
Man sieht es ja hier auch am Anfang.
Guck, das ist so ein Lederband.
Mit so einen Noppen drunter.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das hier irgendwo sieht.
Guck hier, hier sieht man es.
Das drückt übelst auf den Kopf nach einer Zeit.
Richtig beschissen.
Da hab ich so billige
Schaumstoffzeugs drunter
dran gepappt.
Mal das AKG K240 probieren.
Aber im Prinzip hat sich meine Meinung über die meisten
Gaming-Headsets nicht geändert.
Headsets sind immer noch überteuerte Plastik-Schrott.
Was hast du davon?
Wenn du ein Mikro dran hast.
Dafür quasi
80 Euro bezahlst
und 15 Euro für den Kopfhörer.
So, also.
Wir löschen das Ding aus der Datenbank.
Und jetzt sagen wir
Filename.
In Filename steht
bloß die Endung drin.
Also sowas wie hier bla bla bla bla bla
.png.
Das bedeutet, einfach löschen
können wir das nicht. Aber wir können sagen
System
IO
Übrigens falls ihr mal, das ist auch für die Leute
die neu mit C-Sharp anfangen
falls ihr mal Dateisystem-Fade
zusammengesetzt müsst.
Also sowas hier.
Man neigt dazu
sowas hier zu machen.
Und das sage ich auch gleich schon, das ist nicht schön.
Man neigt dazu sowas hier zu machen.
Sowas hier in der Richtung.
Danach macht man dann irgendwann
sowas hier
Guck mal, das spackt schon übelst rum.
Das geht schon gar nicht mehr. Ach so, weil ich das escaped hab.
So, sowas hier. Und danach holt man
sich dynamisch was anderes her.
Und dann sagt man Pass. Plus gleich
irgendwas. Stream.
Noch was.
So, und jetzt hast du das Problem.
Hab ich jetzt hier schon einen Slash hinten dran gemacht.
Muss ich den jetzt hier noch hinzufügen?
Das wird ziemlich inkonsistent.
Und vor allem
sehr fehleranfällig mit der Zeit.
Und nervig zu schreiben.
Muss man auch noch sagen, ja.
Deswegen, wenn man Fade zusammenfügen will
immer System
IO
Pass verwenden. Combine.
Das ist dann relativ simpel damit.
Weil das macht alles für einen schon.
Da gibts einfach die Teile vom Fad an
und der macht dir einen ordentlichen Fad drauf.
So wie es unter Windows funktioniert.
Und ich kann jetzt sagen
ich will aus meinem
Environment, also
aus meiner umgebungsvariablen
Zeugs von ASP.NET Core
möchte ich meinen Content Fad haben.
Mein Content Fad ist der hier.
Der ist immer relativ zur Anwendung.
An diesem Fall ist es halt der hier.
www.root-content
Und
darin suche ich jetzt
die Datei MemeFileName.
Und da kommt jetzt der richtige Fad
raus, den ich brauche.
Nämlich dieser Fad
mit diesem Dateinamen.
Zum Beispiel hinten dran.
Und da kann ich jetzt im Endeffekt sagen
löschen.
Delete. Hier heißt es
Delete. Warum auch immer.
Das unterschiedlich heißt.
Jetzt kann ich es löschen. Das Ding kackt ab.
Sollte es das nicht geben. Aber
da muss schon einer von Hand rumgespielt haben, dass es weg ist.
Ich habe das K700.
Das hat ein flaches Band.
Also mein 701
hat so einen
so einen Ding.
So was da.
Ich sehe
anscheinend haben das nicht alle.
Die neueren anscheinend nicht mehr.
Die halten das und das ist
richtig unbequem.
Ich glaube
FileDeleteRoute. Also ich glaube das
wirft eine Exception, wenn es das nicht gibt.
Ja siehst du
ArgumentException, NotFoundException
das wirft auf jeden Fall
eine Exception. Aber da
scheißen wir erstmal drauf.
Das File muss ja da sein.
Wenn der DB Eintrag noch da ist.
Es sei denn das hat irgendjemand im File System rumgespielt.
Twitch geht wieder. Ne?
Twitch hatte Probleme.
Ich hatte nämlich vorher auch Probleme
mit Twitch.
Solltest du das nicht
catchen? Ach was.
Macht ASP für mich automatisch.
Also mein erster Macht ist wirklich automatisch.
Wenn in einem
Request
eine Exception auftritt, dann kackt
nur der Request ab und die anderen gehen noch.
Und die nächsten
gehen auch wieder.
Natürlich ist trotzdem die bessere
Variante das ganze zu catchen. Das ist schon
richtig. So jetzt
haben wir das File löschen wir.
Ja das war's.
Jetzt haben wir das File gelöscht.
Wir haben das Bild ist
weg. Die
das Meme ist weg. Und jetzt
ganz wichtig was wir zum Schluss noch machen müssen. Wir müssen
unseren Client
informieren.
Dass
sich das ganze
geupdatet hat.
Wir müssen unseren Client informieren, dass sich das
geupdatet hat, weil
der hier muss sich ja reloaden.
Der muss ja seine Bildchen
reloaden.
Systemal ausüberflüssig, ja
tatsächlich.
Warum habe ich denn das
gemacht? Ah ich weiß
warum.
Ähm
weil File
ne
was internes von meinem Controller ist.
Deswegen habe ich das da vorgemacht.
Ich hätte es eigentlich nur vor File machen müssen, aber
ich finde das sieht was besser. Weil das da
herkommt.
So. Ähm
Moin. Was
that was Juni.
Genau.
So. Jetzt sollte das ganze löschen.
Blablabla. Okay.
Ähm.
Refresh Clients.
Das
könnte tatsächlich jetzt sogar
einfach gehen.
Das könnte jetzt sogar einfach
funktionieren.
Ich mache mal hier einen Breakpoint hin.
Oder mal hier
einen Breakpoint hin,
dass ich das mitkriege, ob es auch wirklich funktioniert.
Okay. Ähm.
Erstmal Refreshen.
Delete.
Ah wir landen schon mal da drinnen.
Continue. Return.
Ist weg.
Das war ja einfach.
Wir sollten noch das Overlay schließen lassen
vorher.
Ähm.
Popup
visible
visible.
Das war jetzt aber kein großer Akt.
Gucken wir nochmal.
Upload. Zack.
Delete.
Jaja. Breakpoint.
Und es ist weg.
Wunderbar.
Das war jetzt mal Massive easy würde ich sagen.
Oh. Chat ist ganz viel
rot drinnen.
Delphi 6. Oh. Das aber schon.
Was kommt dem heutzutage am nächsten?
Hm.
Naja.
Ich sag mal so.
Es sieht zwar anders aus.
Aber
ich würde tatsächlich C Sharp lernen.
Weil was du wissen musst ist, dass der
Oberdesigner von
Delphi 6 C Sharp mitentwickelt hat.
Also vielleicht wirst du da doch
die ein oder anderen Sachen finden, die dir
gefallen.
Ansonsten
sieht er aus wie Delphi
bzw. wie Pascal.
Bruechel Basic, aber das will man nicht.
Ähm.
Beut das auch nicht.
Mir fällt eigentlich nichts ein, was ähnlich aussieht
wie Pascal.
Ruby kannst du aussehen lassen
wie du willst.
Ich würde mich C Sharp angucken.
Allein schon weil der ehemalige
Delphi Typ mitentwickelt hat.
Die ursprüngliche Version.
Aber TypeScript am Start.
Wann kann man dich endlich bei Twitch abonnieren?
Ja, wenn ich Affiliate oder Partner
Stelle endlich mal mache.
Was ist wichtiger bei einem Monitor? Die Herzzahl oder G-Sync?
Die Herzzahl.
Wobei du wirst keinen 144 Hertz Monitor finden, der
also, nein umgekehrt, du wirst keinen G-Sync
Monitor finden, der nicht auch 144 Hertz kann.
Aber ich finde ehrlich gesagt
persönlich finde ich G-Sync ziemlich
sinnlos.
Also G-Sync ist nichts, wo ich wirklich Wert
drauf liegen würde beim Monitor Kauf.
Mal random gefragt, ist C Sharp mehr Java
oder C++?
Es liegt, also
Syntaktisch vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Java.
Aber es hat
Syntaktisch und von dem Level
auf dem man
sich bewegt, ist es eindeutig
mehr Java. Ich meine doch standardmäßig
auch deine Bytecode VM drunter.
Aber sie haben sich von manchen Sachen inspirieren
lassen. Und du hast auch einen Unsafe Mode, wo du ein paar
ekliche Dinger machen kannst, aber das macht man eigentlich
normalerweise nicht.
Ehe Java.
Ja, der Chat sieht es genauso.
Der Boynextdoor ist auch wieder am Start.
Kennst du den guten
UHD Monitor? Nee.
Ich habe seit Jahren hier
mir einen, ich habe vor Jahren
144 Hertz BenQ Monitor gekauft
und den habe ich seitdem. Und
das nächste, was ich mir holen werde, ist ein
4K, ein
4K 144 Hertz
Monitor. Also das, was es jetzt neu gibt,
von Asus und ich glaube
Dell. Und wenn sich das etabliert hat
und die Dinger nicht mal 1800 Euro kosten,
dann hole ich mir sowas als nächstes.
Ansonsten bleibt es erst mal so wie es ist.
Warum nicht Visual Basic?
Hab ich durchaus gut darüber gehört.
Weil Visual Basic,
VisualBasic.net
ist...
Du kannst damit alles machen, was du mit C-Sharp
und F-Sharp auch machen kannst. Ich meine es ist letztendlich
.NET unten drunter. Aber
wenn man sich mal anguckt, was Support
von Microsoft angeht und was es für Tutorials
gibt und wie
wo neue Features eingebaut werden, ist der Fokus
von Microsoft eindeutig auf C-Sharp und
F-Sharp und nicht mehr auf Visual Basic.
Und wird es wahrscheinlich auch nie wieder sein.
Und dazu kommt, dass
C-Sharp auch einfach viel, viel verbreiteter ist.
Als Visual Basic.NET.
Für.NET Zeug.
Habt ihr...
Es gibt ja jetzt hier von Asus
diesen 4K 144Hz
mit Lüfter.
Das ist geil. Das ist der erste Monitor mit Lüfter.
Der wird zu heiß.
Push to the Challenges eigentlich am Ende vom Stream nochmal.
Ne, das mache ich nächste Woche,
wenn ich, oder am Wochenende,
wenn diese Version
hier alle grundlegende Funktionen hat,
die sein müssen.
Dann mache ich auch einen Installer und das kann jeder verwenden.
Genau, das ist der erste Monitor
hier mit Lüfter.
Genau.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ja, hier drin ist ein Lüfter.
Man hört nichts.
Aber der Lüfter ist nervig.
Das habe ich in einem Video gesehen.
Ups.
Naja, wirklich hört man es nicht.
Aber ich habe es in einem Video gesehen,
dass der Lüfter nervig ist.
Ich meine, allen Ernstes ein Monitor mit Lüfter.
Lull, oder?
Ein bisschen off-topic.
Perfektes Setup,
um mit Linux und Windows an einem PC zu benutzen.
Mein Problem
in einer Lübungsvirtual-Maschine
mit VirtualBox gestartet,
mit UEFI, also
ich persönlich benutze immer VirtualBox,
äh, nicht VirtualBox,
vor allem bei Workstation.
Vor allem bei Workstation.
Beste.
Wir können das Ding gerade mal starten,
können wir uns angucken.
Nein, nein, nein, nein,
mein Mikrofon möchte ich da nicht dran attachen.
So, ich starte mal kurz neu.
Dass man das sieht.
So, also das, ähm,
funktioniert wunderbar.
Kann ich eigentlich nur empfehlen.
Hallo.
Bam.
Off.
Quatsch, das ist ein Test.
So, und wenn man sich jetzt hier die Oberfläche anguckt,
da kann man sich eigentlich nicht beschweren.
Also das Terminal ist zackig.
Der Browser ist zackig.
Ähm, was
in der VM prinzipiell nicht gut funktioniert,
ist, ähm,
also hier gehen wir hier über Stream, sonst was,
zack. Also das geht, das geht
eigentlich schon schnell, also da kann man sich wirklich
nicht beschweren
hier, ne.
Zumal ich halt mit X3 auch
keine Fenster habe, sondern alles
auf dem Screen.
Ja,
auch wenn man zum Beispiel Studio Code aufmacht,
das funktioniert wirklich gut, da kann man sich eigentlich überhaupt
nicht beschweren. Auch, auch
Browsern hier im
Browser wunderbar, kein Ding.
Funktioniert wunderbar.
Was nicht funktioniert, aber das ist VM
bedingt, VM war bedingt,
bzw. allgemein virtualisierung bedingt,
sind, ähm,
sind Videos, also sie funktionieren
schon,
sie funktionieren schon, also an sich kein
Problem, aber
es hat halt ordentlich,
wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt,
es hat halt ordentlich CPU-Auslastung.
Weil
in der VM hast du halt keinen
GPU-Decoding.
Kein Hardware-H264-Decoder,
das muss halt alles CPU-mäßig machen.
Das ist auch das, warum Multimedia-Sachen
überhaupt keinen Bock in der VM machen.
Da kann man leider nichts dran ändern.
Das ist halt leider so aktuell.
Hast du ein Multi-Monitor-Sender?
Nee, ich habe zwei Rechner und jeweils ein Monitor dran.
Ich könnte den Monitor
vom zweiten Rechner auch auf dem
anderen, also der ist auch am anderen Rechner angeschlossen.
Ich könnte den als
Multi-Monitor-Setup verwenden,
aber den zweiten Rechner
mache ich halt an, wenn ich streame. Ich habe hier links auf dem
Monitor habe ich halt,
Follows, Chat,
Vorschau-Bild und
hier ist halt das,
was ihr auch seht im Endeffekt drauf.
Wie viel schneller
ist es denn zum Beispiel
ein Array mit
100.000
Ins zu kopieren,
zu save und unsave?
Ich würde sagen,
das macht bei 100.000
Einträgen gar nicht so viel aus.
Der macht ja unter der Haube jetzt auch
keine großartig komplizierten
Dinger.
Also Arrays kopieren ist
wahrscheinlich kein Ding.
Wahrscheinlich kein Ding.
Was ein Problem ist,
also so ein Problem was,
nennen wir es mal Managed-Sprachen haben,
also sprich irgendwas mit einem
Garbage-Collector dabei oder
also sei es jetzt die Sharp Java oder sonst was,
wenn du schnell
ganz ganz viele Objekte erzeugst,
also richtig viele,
dann ist das manchmal relativ
langsam
im Vergleich zu unmanaged.
Aber das ist halt was du für
ein Ding durch den Garbage-Collector
bezahlst im Endeffekt.
Wobei sie das jetzt auch angegangen sind
in C Sharp, weil
die haben ja unter anderem selbst festgestellt,
dass es ein bisschen blöd ist,
dass man zum Beispiel
Arrays
laufend irgendwie kopieren
muss
und nicht gescheit splitten kann
und sowas in der Richtung.
Ohne quasi wieder
komplett neues Objekt zu machen.
Das gibt es jetzt in der neuen
in einer neuen C Sharp Version gibt es jetzt
Span
und das ist quasi
ein
Warte mal, war das Span?
Ich glaube das war Span. Ja genau, Span und Memory T.
Richtig, genau. Und das ist
quasi ein
View auf das Array.
Also sprich
eine read-only
Sicht
auf das Array.
Wo du dann halt auch
quasi das Array in unterschiedliche Teile
zerschneiden kannst, ohne
dass du unten drunter jedes Mal
ein neues Array anlegen musst, sondern du kannst
dann sagen, ich splitte das Array jetzt,
meine 100.000
Inns, die ich habe in deinem Beispiel,
splitte ich jetzt in jeweils 100
100er Plöcke oder in 100er
1.000er Plöcke und
früher musste ich
tatsächlich dann
100 neue Arrays anlegen
mit jeweils 1.000 Inns drinne.
Das muss ich jetzt nicht mehr. Jetzt kann ich 100 Spans
anlegen, die auf das
ursprüngliche Array zeigen.
Und ich glaube die sind sogar, ich glaube Spans
sind noch nicht mal read-only.
Also
die haben das selbst gemerkt, dass das
keine allzu gute Idee ist. Ja genauso
auch mit langen Strings und
sowas. Du machst halt bei jedem
Editieren quasi einen neuen String
und dafür ist das auch
da. Und das ist halt ziemlich cool.
Und
du hast natürlich so rein
Raw-Performance mäßig.
Wenn es jetzt halt auch tatsächlich drauf ankommt
hast du schon mit sowas
wie Rust oder C++ Vorteile.
Aber, das muss man auch mal ganz klar sagen
Es sind
also du
kannst jetzt nicht, wenn du dir
was überlegt hast, was
nicht richtig optimiert ist, dann ist das auch
nicht in C auf einmal
gottgegeben ultra schnell
und in C sharp mega langsam.
Das sind, wenn überhaupt dann ganz spezielle Fälle
und die sieht Microsoft meistens auch irgendwie als Bugs.
Da sieht man nämlich schon daran, dass wenn man sich hier mal
ähm
Web Framework
Benchmarks anguckt
dann sieht man
das ASP.NET
mit das
schnellste ist
mit allen Features drinnen.
Ja, die letzte Benchmarkrunde ist vom
6.6.
Und auf Platz 7
ist
geht schon los mit ASP.NET Core.
Allerdings mit
Raw-Datenbank-Access auf Postgres
wie es aussieht. Also nicht komplett
full featured. So. Und wenn man mal hier
nach
gucken wir mal hier
Entity Framework Postgres.
So.
Das ist zwar viel langsamer, aber wenn man sich mal anguckt
die anderen Frameworks
die man so kennt, die sind entweder noch langsamer
oder ziemlich in der Nähe.
Guck, hier hast du Node.js neben dran
irgendwo.
Das ist schon ziemlich schnell.
Und wenn du mal anguckst, die ganze
Raw, also ASP.NET Core
mit
quasi mehr oder weniger von Hand gebasteltem
Datenbank-Access
ist auf Platz 7 von den Web Frameworks.
Und ist mit Sicherheit immer noch
deutlich angenehmer zu benutzen als
die obere, die ich ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht kenne.
Also das ist schon schnell
mittlerweile. Das ist wirklich saumäßig
schnell mittlerweile.
Also da ist nichts
von irgendwie Faktor 100
oder so zu erwarten. Also nur weil du jetzt
irgendwie was in C machst, ist das nicht automatisch 100 mal
schneller als in C Sharp. Die sind da mittlerweile
schon ziemlich gut dabei.
Benutzt du eigentlich für das
Frontend Vanilla.js oder Framework Review?
Das ist Vue.js hier. Guck da.
Vue.js
Vue ist richtig gut.
Nichts vorher mitgemacht.
Außer jetzt für das Projekt hier und ich muss sagen
ich bin da voll überzeugt
von. Richtig gut.
Und Visual Studio.
Visual Studio ist auch toll. Also für mich ist Visual Studio
die beste Idee die es gibt.
Es gibt Fernsehen mit Lüfte. Ernsthaft.
Warum verwendest du englisches Tastaturlayout?
Mach ich nicht.
Ich verwende englische Betriebssystemsprache
und German Tastaturlayout.
Warum Windows hier unten die Sprache anzeigt
anstatt das Tastaturlayout was an eigentlich hauptsächlich
interessiert. Weiß ich nicht. Ich musste Microsoft fragen.
Weil. Weil. Keine Ahnung. Weil Windows.
Es gibt viele Sachen die
versteht man nicht so genau.
Was passiert eigentlich wenn man
Vmware in Vmware benutzt?
Dann benutzt du nested virtualization.
Da gibt es sogar ein Wort für.
Was sagst du zu der Übernahme von Red Hat durch IBM?
Ernsthaft? Das hab ich doch überhaupt nicht gelesen.
Wirklich?
Das heißt ab jetzt werden Red Hat
Produkte scheiße.
Hab ich doch gar nicht gesehen.
Ich bin ja kein großer Fan. Muss ich gleich dazu sagen.
Auch wenn es businessmäßig voll angesagt ist.
Und wir haben auf der Arbeit auch
Red Hat Enterprise Linux.
Aber.
Ich bin da kein großer Fan von.
Aber es ist mit Sicherheit alles mal noch besser
als das was IBM so fabrizieren wird.
Ok.
Das heißt ab jetzt wird es sacken.
Weil im Prinzip fast alles sackt was von IBM ist.
Guckt euch mal Nodes an.
Nodes ist der größte Bullshit aller Zeiten.
Muss einer von euch doch nur das Nodes verwenden
oder IBM Nodes oder wie auch immer es genau heißt.
Also wie es mittlerweile sich nennt.
Wann würde sich denn dann Unsafe
lohnen?
Unsafe lohnt sich
nicht.
Unsafe brauchst du eigentlich hauptsächlich
im Zusammenarbeit
im Zusammenspiel
mit native Windows APs
oder mit C Libraries
oder so die du ansprechen willst. Ansonsten brauchst du eigentlich kaum
Unsafe.
Oder zum Beispiel wenn du
die Dime und X Sachen machen musst. Da brauchst du auch ab und zu
mal Unsafe Geschichten.
Ansonsten brauchst du eigentlich nie
Unsafe.
Gefällt mir jetzt auch kein
gescheites Beispiel vor allem.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Safe und Unsafe?
Safe und Unsafe also
Safe Code ist alles.
Standardmäßig ist alles Safe.
Wenn ich was Unsafe machen
will, dann muss ich explizit sagen
ich kann jetzt hier drin grad nicht tippen
dann muss ich explizit sagen
Unsafe.
Und hier drinnen garbage collector
dann wahrscheinlich auch nichts und hier
drin kann ich auch Pointer verwenden
für alle Pointer Fans.
Kann man Pointer verwenden und halt native Funktionen
und sowas aufrufen.
Wo man halt nicht weiß was
am Ende passieren wird. Ich könnte da auch irgendwelche
Überläufe oder
sonst was produzieren. Was mir in
Safe Code halt nicht passieren kann.
Aber ich finde es cool. Es ist schön
dass du das mir jetzt gesagt hast. Mal mit IBM
und Red Hat. Weil
das hätte ich bis morgen überhaupt nicht mitgekriegt.
Interessant.
Aber ich habe
ja das Gefühl es wird jetzt einfach kacke werden.
Alles von Red Hat.
Red Hat hat ja heute schon so den Anstrich, dass sie
quasi sehr viel machen, weil
es halt Business ist. Und halt was
Business Leute wollen. Und das ist dann technisch
nicht unbedingt immer so das Schönste.
Aber das hat immer Hand und Fuß.
Aber wenn das jetzt IBM hat.
Ich mein, guckt euch mal die IBM Seite an.
Ach Moment. Das ist ja gar nicht bei IBM.
Das ist ja mittlerweile Lenovo, ne?
Was hat IBM überhaupt noch?
Also früher.
Als ich doch auf die IBM
Seite musste.
Wegen IBM Servern, die sie
auf die IBM Seite
wegen IBM Servern, die sie jetzt
anscheinend auch an Lenovo
out gedingst haben.
Das war die hässlichste und am eklig zu
benutzendste Seite überhaupt. Das war so schlimm.
Das war wirklich schlimm.
Auf einem neun Jahre alten
Rechner VMs laufen lassen?
Ja. Ja, das geht.
Gibt ja auch Listen. Diese sind besser als Arrays.
Es kommt drauf an.
Also prinzipiell ist eine Liste nicht besser als ein Array.
Ein Array ist, wenn man es ganz genau nimmt,
mit Sicherheit die Datenstruktur,
die weniger
jetzt kommt es so, dass das Basis schlecht in
der Head hat. Ein Array ist im Prinzip einfach
ganz simpel Speicher am Stück
fertig. Für genauso viele Elemente,
wie du es brauchst. Kannst du nicht verkleinern,
kannst du nicht vergrößern, ist auch ein weiteres
gutes. Aber trotzdem
würde ich auch immer Listen verwenden.
Einfach weil das deutlich praktischer ist.
Mit Span kannst du glaube ich keine Sachen
hinzufügen. Ne. Span
ist ja quasi kein eigenes Array, sondern
quasi ein Zeiger
auf dein ursprüngliches Array.
Ich glaube aber, man kann mit Memory
T oder wie das heißt. Ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ich kenne bloß die Vorträge von der letzten Bild.
Kannst du
auf die Elemente Read-Write zugreifen.
Ich bin so lahm
heute mit dem Chat. Ist ja schlimm. Ich komme überhaupt nicht
hinterher. Zum Programmieren kommen wir auch nicht wirklich.
Wir haben es jetzt zumindest schon geschafft,
dass, okay
ich sollte die Anwendung mal wieder starten, dass wir jetzt
Sachen löschen können. Das ist doch schon mal schön.
Das ist doch schon mal was. Wir können
Sachen löschen.
Anker Giga.
Ja ja ja.
Jabbaded.
Ist das etwa der Tio? Ja das ist der Tio.
Der Tio spielt immer Skyrim.
So, ich glaube jetzt bin ich
mit dem Chat fast wieder unten.
Was hältst du von
Funktionalen Programmiersprachen wie
F-Sharp und H-Scan?
Ich habe da viel zu wenig was mit gemacht.
Jetzt habe ich da was zu sagen kann.
Also
die einzige Programmiersprache, die
man quasi Funktional nennen kann
und mit der ich ein bisschen was gemacht habe
ist Lisp. Weil
Emacs,
Emacs Fan ja
ist aber auch schon ein bisschen
eingeschlafen.
Das benutze ich eigentlich schon eine Weile nicht mehr.
Magst du es abgelehnt für einen
Minecraft Server zu programmieren? Hab ich?
Hab ich das echt?
Was gibt es dafür?
Kennst du den YouTube-Channel Basta?
Ja klar, kenne ich.
C-Sharp zum Kurs lernen, das kenne ich auch.
Das kenne ich, das kenne ich den Vortrag.
Schon mal ganz klassisch was mit Assembler gemacht.
Also
nichts, wo am Ende was Sinnvolles bei
herausgekommen wäre.
Eher nur so ein bisschen
rumspielen.
Also
nichts, wo am Ende was Sinnvolles bei
herausgekommen wäre.
Eher nur so ein bisschen rumspielen.
Freiwillig Java?
Nein.
Das würde ich nur machen
und ich weiß, dass der Minecraft Server
ein Java ist. Das würde ich nur machen, wenn es
irgendwelche Anreize gäbe.
Ich meine damit jetzt nicht, dass ich irgendwie dicke Kohle verkriege.
Irgendwas, wo ich sagen würde, ja dafür lohnt es sich.
Ja bait it
Jungs.
Der Server ist jetzt down, 1000 Spieler sind deswegen gequettet.
Warum ist der Server down?
Da kann ich, also da muss ich jetzt sagen,
da kann ich ja jetzt nur wirklich nichts für.
Aber 1000 Spieler
ist schon ordentlich.
Ich hatte ja auch mal eine Minecraft Server
vor einigen Jahren,
ist schon eine ganze Weile her.
Das war eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Ich bin schon mit der Lena rumgestellt auf dem Server, glaube ich.
Das muss schon eine ganze Weile
her sein.
Aber da hatten wir nie
1000 Spieler, da hatten wir vielleicht irgendwie 300 oder so.
Insgesamt.
Es gibt einen Max FPS Minecraft Trailer.
Es haben auch irgendwelche Leute Kekse gebaut.
Genau.
Ich erinnere mich noch.
Gibt es das lange Lachs Video?
Das war das, oder?
Ich weiß nicht.
Das war das Video doch, oder?
Wo ich mit dem Kabum rumgelaufen bin,
das war aber...
Der Entwickler
von Minecraft ist mit Java
reich geworden.
Ich würde sagen, da ist erstmal mit
seiner Idee reich geworden.
Und, was man ja auch nicht vergessen darf,
mit den
tausenden Leuten,
die dafür
Content entwickelt haben.
Weil
Minecraft an sich
eigentlich
nicht so
weil Minecraft an sich
war ja, zumindest in der Auslieferungsvariante
von ein paar Jahren war das ja ziemlich
roh, ja.
Von Addons, von Server, Spielmodi,
von alles, ja.
Was hältst du von
Mono-Develop nicht so viel?
Kann man verwenden, wenn es sein muss.
Finde ich jetzt eher nervig.
Also wenn ich eine Cross-Plattform
C-Sharp-IDE brauche,
dann würde ich wahrscheinlich heutzutage Rider nehmen,
von JetBrains.
JetBrains.
Mono-Develop
wird schlinks liegen lassen.
Der Java-Hatred.
Ich mache da auch immer gerne mit.
Auf der Arbeit ist unser meistes Zeug auch in Java.
Weil halt Business.
Und Business-Dinger sind halt
Java.
Schon mal Kotlin in freier Wildbahn
erlebt? Ne, habe ich noch nicht.
Ähm, soll ja angeblich
die einzig gescheite Sprache
neben Groovy auf der Java-VM sein.
Na gut, gibt es noch mehr.
Scala, Scala, nicht auch.
Java-VM.
Oder was, Erlang?
Ne, ja, Scala, oder?
Scala ist das doch, wo die,
das was von aus Klammern besteht,
die ganze, alles.
Durch Minecraft,
äh, durch Fortnite ist Minecraft
jetzt ziemlich tot.
Echt?
Ja.
Max, schau dir mal
meinen Twitch-Namen an, der stellt so.
Ja, das ist
guter Name.
So muss das sein.
Oh, der Frisur streamt,
erhausten.
Also, ich denke mal, dass wir nächste Woche
mit dem Programm soweit fertig sind,
dass wir da mal eine erste Version raushauen können,
die alle grundlegenden Sachen hat.
Im Prinzip fehlen jetzt ja eigentlich nur noch
zwei Sachen, zwei grundlegende
Dinge, die ich noch einbauen will. Wie gesagt,
einmal, dass man eben die Sachen ordentlich
editieren kann,
löschen kann man sie mittlerweile, editieren kann man sie
noch nicht richtig, dass man favorisieren kann
und es dann halt ordentlich sortiert.
Ja.
Ja, und dass man
nicht nur Bilder, sondern auch
Text-Dateien, äh,
nicht Text-Dateien, also
Audio-Dateien zusätzlich
hinterlegen kann, weil aktuell kann man ja nur
Bilder reinmachen
und Text-to-Speech
sich vorlesen lassen, wenn man will.
Aber es wäre halt schön, wenn es
noch ein richtiges Audio-Datei unterstützt, ja.
Dann könnte man es jetzt hier zum Beispiel
verlassen, wenn man das gerne hätte.
Muss mir relativ schnell
für meine Ausbildung eine
Cross-Platform-IDE suchen, da mein Laptop
Linux hat und die aber
RIDER.
RIDER oder aber
du verwendest Visual Studio Code.
Weil das ist für einen Einstieg vollkommen
in Ordnung.
.NET Core drauf, Visual Studio Code
drauf
und
einfach das Projekt öffnen und erledigt
alles runter, was du brauchst.
Hat sogar ganz guten
Debugger-Support.
Nicht so schön wie Visual Studio oder nicht so schön wie RIDER,
aber es ist zum Einstieg vollkommen in Ordnung.
Warum nur 1080p
verfügbar ist, weil
ich heute keine
Qualitätsoptionen gekriegt habe.
Das wird immer einmal entschieden,
wenn man den Stream anmacht,
habe ich zumindest das Gefühl, wenn man den Stream
anmacht und gerade
genug Kapazitäten frei sind.
Es sei denn, man ist Affiliate oder Partner. Partner kriegst du quasi
immer und als Affiliate wahrscheinlich auch
meistens, aber als Nicht-Partner
immer, wenn was frei ist. Ansonsten hast du Pech.
Und heute hatte ich halt Pech.
Was, wenn du heute
zu Tag durch die Schule gehst, hörst du nur auf Fortnite?
Ah ja, wundert mich nicht.
Ich mein, guckt euch das doch mal an.
Äh, nein, nicht
das Top App.
Ist das der Hanzo im Hintergrund gewesen gerade?
Das sah aus wie Hanzo, oder?
Da, hier, der Typ.
Ne, ne, der andere Typ.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ich mein, guckt euch das doch mal an.
Fortnite.
Die letzten Jahre, also vor Fortnite,
war ja im Prinzip
immer LOL auf dem ersten Platz,
immer. Mittlerweile ist
Fortnite einfach
der grase Shit schlechthin.
Was ein bisschen eingebrochen ist, ist
Pupke, wo ist es? Das ist
meistens aber auch hier unter den ersten Paar. Da,
Pupke. Pupke ist auch noch meistens
relativ weit vorne.
Übrigens ist es schön, dass sie jetzt
die Kategorien umbenannt haben.
Moment, was?
Lineage 2?
Warum hat das
23.000 Zuschauer?
Okay, weil irgendwelche Russen streamen.
Was auch immer.
Also früher war das
ja IRL und
für
alles andere gab es da noch irgendwie
Kunst und Programming
und das hat keiner geguckt. Ich finde es gut,
dass sie Just Chatting haben für IRL
und Science and Technology für alles andere.
Was gibt es denn hier gerade so zu gucken
in Just Chatting?
Dance in the Grills?
Noch mehr Dance in the Grills?
Was geht denn hier ab?
Irgendwie muss man ja auch
seine Zuschauer unterhalten.
Makeup?
Fehlen bloß noch ein paar ASMR Streams
oder so.
Mit Shranken Drops sortieren wäre cool.
Gebe ich dir Recht,
werden wir aber nicht machen. Erstens,
weil, Moment, wo ist es?
Dass
komplizierter ist als man denkt.
Ja, man müsste ja irgendwie
die Position
insgesamt speichern
und das müssen wir dann wahrscheinlich
in den Link Lists im Hintergrund haben.
Und das nächste ist,
die Sachen zu
Shranken Dropen
ist auch gar nicht
so schön eigentlich, weil
du hast dann das Problem,
wenn du das hierhin
Shrackst, ja, wohin soll es
dann hin? Hier dazwischen, okay.
Und was passiert, dann schiebt sich dann alles
eins runter, weil das ist ja kein Crit
im Endeffekt. Das ist kein Crit,
das ist, wenn es ein Crit wäre, wäre es wieder
ekliger, dass es sich anpasst an die
Fenstergröße.
Das ist ja so quasi ein Stack,
du schiebst hier was rein und es geht einfach
flupflupflupflup vor links nach rechts.
Also man könnte das sortierbar machen,
aber ich hab mir da am Anfang schon mal ein bisschen
gedankens- tiefgreifende Gedanken
zugemacht. Fällt jetzt nicht mal alles ein,
aber
es war letztendlich am Ende
den Aufwand nicht mehr. Und
was nämlich die viel einfachere Variante ist,
die ich mir überlegt hab, ist, wir haben
einen Favorisieren-Knopf, den kann man drücken.
Das heißt, wenn man seine
Top 5 Memes immer vorne haben will,
dann macht man einfach Favorite an und gut ist.
Oder aber,
was wir auch noch einbauen werden, ist hier oben
einfach,
auch, also, verschiedene
Kategorien könnte man machen.
Also quasi, je nachdem,
was passt. Eine
Pepe-Kategorie, eine Gasm-
Kategorie, eine
Gift-Kategorie oder so.
Und, also was, das kommt aber erst später,
sowas in der Richtung, aber was ich auf jeden Fall zum Sortieren noch einbaue,
ist, dass man das nach Upload-Datum
sortieren kann. Also sprich, dass man gucken
kann, ok, das ist lange drin, das ist alt drin.
Aber, letztendlich,
man kann einfach suchen danach.
Geht ja auch. Deswegen hab ich
auch die Suche eingebaut.
Hm.
Wie lange programmierst du schon hier dran?
Also,
an Version 2 würde ich mal sagen, so,
was hab ich denn damit angefangen?
Können wir doch gucken, wann wurde denn die,
wann wurde denn
das erstellt?
Sieht man das nicht irgendwo?
Sieht man nicht irgendwo, wann das Projekt erstellt
wurde?
Ich mein, ich kann mir einfach den Ordner
angucken, ne?
Also, das Projekt hier
wurde erstellt am
21.10. um 11.43.
Wobei das nicht ganz stimmt,
da hab ich's hierhin kopiert.
Bisschen vorher.
Ah ja, sag mal mal, so zwei Wochen.
Aber halt
immer mit Pausen dazwischen, ja?
Eigentlich, eigentlich ja immer nur am Wochenende
paar Stunden.
Es ist jetzt ja auch nicht, dass das so
ultra kompliziert ist.
Science and Technology schlecht gewählt, ja?
Aber alle mal besser als das, wie's vorher war.
Ich würd bei VNBA nie
install auswählen.
Genau, Flo690
macht das mal.
Ist die Suche der dies Kleinzeit,
da ist keine große
Magic dahinter.
Die ist ganz billig Kleinzeit.
Aber es ist ja auch
nicht notwendig. Ich mein,
hey, selbst wenn jetzt mal es einer total
übertreibt, ja?
Der hat da drin vielleicht maximal 500
Bilder. Und 500 Bilder
quasi den Text
und den Name zu durchsuchen
ist ja überhaupt kein Ding, ja?
Also sollte es wirklich
notwendig sein, baue ich noch eine
Sortierfunktion ein.
Aber ich glaube, es ist besser, man kann
die Dinger nach Kategorien
kopieren, man kann danach suchen, man kann sie favorisieren
und man kann nach Upload-Datum
suchen. Ich glaube, das ist die bessere Variante.
Oh, das ist eine interessante Frage,
Aro-Mur, ich habe Angst davor, dass wenn ich
Vollzeit arbeite,
gar keine Lust mehr auf
eigene Projekte habe, wie ist das bei dir?
Doch, hab ich. Es liegt
einfach daran, dass
man,
sag mal so, in der
Enterprise-Umgebung, ja?
Da halten sich Innovationen
und
Sachen, die man machen will, relativ
in Grenzen, ja?
Also zumindest so im Versicherung-Banksektor,
wo ich ja am Start bin.
Es ist nicht so, dass es keinen Spaß macht oder so.
Aber sowas kann ich da nicht machen.
Das ist schon teilweise relativ trocken,
wenn man sich so anguckt, ja?
Es ist eigentlich eher so, dass man sich die coole,
dass man vielleicht manchmal auf coole Ideen
ankommt und das daheim mal ein bisschen ausprobiert.
Aber so wirklich auslasten
kannst du dich ja eh nur bei eigenen Sachen.
Ich benutze keinen Skype mehr.
Ich benutze nur Discord.
Das ist das einzige, was ich mir vorstellen kann,
ehrlich gesagt.
Was ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen
könnte, ist irgendwie so Marketing-
BWL-Bullshit-Gelaber.
Da krieg ich immer Anfälle.
Wenn ich da irgendwie so spezielle Kandidaten
habe, äh,
der Theo spielt schon wieder Skyrim.
Der spielt immer Skyrim.
Es ist nicht möglich zu abonnieren.
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß. Ich guck mal,
dass ich das irgendwie hinkrieg.
Du bist nicht mehr in der IT?
Doch, doch. Bin ich. Bin ich.
Bin ich.
Ich mein,
man
lernt ja da schon ganz coole Sachen, ja.
Ich mein,
ohne dass ich das jetzt jahrelang gemacht hätte,
dort wo ich bin, wäre ich nie auf die Idee gekommen,
mir ne, ne, ne, ne, ne,
eigene Server-Rack daheim hinzustellen.
Auch wenn da nicht viel drinne ist im Vergleich
zu einem richtigen Rack, ja.
Das hätt ich so wahrscheinlich nicht gemacht.
Da hätt ich wahrscheinlich, wie jeder andere,
so ne 0815 Fritzbox daheim
und nen QNAP-Nass
oder sowas.
Oder noch besser, ne Nass aufm USB-Stick
an der Fritzbox.
Das ist das räudigste Nass, was man sich
vorstellen kann, ey.
Vor 100 Jahren wäre Max
arbeitslos. Das ist richtig, ja.
Vor 100 Jahren hast du noch ganz andere Sachen
gebraucht als heute.
Aber umgedreht auch.
Vor, vor 500 Jahren
hätt ich die Leute bestimmt Ablassbriefe verkauft oder so.
Was?
Hätt ich das gar maßt.
Ne, also ich würd,
ja, ist immer die Frage, was man macht, ja.
Also, IT-Technisch.
Ich bin am überlegen aktuell,
ob ich mir nicht nächstes Jahr was anderes suche.
Einfach, dass ich auch mal ein bisschen was anderes sehe
und außerdem gibt es ein paar Dinge, die mir
zu enterprise-ig sind
mittlerweile und zu
business-mäßig bei uns, ja.
Man muss nicht wegen jedem, man muss nicht jeden Mist
totmieten und man muss auch nicht
zu jedem Mist
irgendeine Retrospektive machen und
ja, also
manche Sachen nerven mich schon
ein bisschen.
Ich mein, letztendlich ist es auch nicht schlecht, ja.
Da kann man immer sagen,
who cares, juck mich nicht.
Was man bei vielen Sachen, ja,
nach einer Zeit zwangsläufig macht.
Also ich überleg mal, ob ich mir nächstes Jahr nicht was anderes suche.
Außerdem gibt es ein paar Leute bei uns, die mir echt auf den Keks gehen.
Wann kommt endlich Video mit Kaboom?
Tja, das ist die Frage
der Fragen.
Warum machst du einen Server weg zu Hause?
Weil, damit ich die Technik irgendwo reinstellen kann.
Guck da hier, das.
Das da.
Da ist es,
da ist es,
da sieht man es von vorne.
Es wird aber alles dieses Jahr
noch ein bisschen downcreated.
Weil, die 4HE-Kiste
da oben so geil ist.
Einfach masslos oversized ist
blockchain integration natürlich ist halt alles blockchain integration heute
ne ich werde mir ich werde mir was suchen also ich werde einfach mal gucken was es so gibt
für gelegenheiten hier aktuell und dann mal gucken eigentlich geht es mir hauptsächlich
darum ein bisschen mal ein bisschen um zu gucken was es eigentlich so gibt also wenn
jemand ein krasse job angeboten hat dann nur her damit das immer dabei je nachdem was es ist
so ja mehr machen wir da nicht mehr also nicht mehr programmier zeugs hier ich gucke jetzt mal
dass ich noch alles beantworte was im chat so kam max wie geht es dem friseur noch kontakt mit
ihm klar dem geht es gut der steht auch gerade falls du gucken willst wie es ihm geht mach mal
ausrufe zeichen friseur im chat das sind link zu seinem channel der ist auch gerade am start
ach ja stimmt wir wollten die steam angebote noch gucken ja was haben wir dann noch also
wahrscheinlich ziemlich nice also der erste teil war ganz cool shadow of the tomb raider
das ist das ist shadow of the tomb raider ist das das neue oder der zweite teil der zweite teil
vom reboot also ist das der da dieses jahr rausgekommen ist oder das das dazwischen
das neue ok
warum warum hat es schlechte bewertung sagt das ist nicht gut
mix
wie dass ich beschwert das ist beck voll der ist geiler typ
wie sie sich aufregen dass das game immer billiger ist wahrscheinlich hat sich nicht
so gut verkauft die wollen ein bisschen was raushauen aber ich meine letztendlich ist
doch ihre schuld wenn sie das so schön wenn sie das gekauft haben damals
manche steam bewertungen sind beknackt selten eine schlechte bewertung ja es gibt
dachten die musst du dir verstehen ich war die hier schreiben sie wenigstens ausführlich ja
warum ist es schwarz warum ist das schwarz hier ist das ach das ist spoiler das ist spoiler
die schreiben ist ja relativ ausführlich die leute muss man sagen
ok was haben wir sonst noch so im sale schönes vampire sagt mir gar nichts
sagt mir gar nichts das game taugt es was
fullscreen geht schon mal nicht fullscreen ist gebetet
schreckt das sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus mostly positive
jetzt auch nicht so der reißer irgendwie wie immer der klassiker quasi schon das ist auch
ein game das spricht mich so überhaupt nicht an das das tisen sie ja schon quasi seit dem
release der xbox 1 haben sie das ja geteased immer wieder das game und ich muss ehrlich sagen ich
habe keine ahnung ob das game gut oder schlecht ist aber ich finde dieser art style der irgendwie
regt mich auf wenn ich ihn sehe das passiert nicht oft aber ich ich mir gefällt es überhaupt nicht
mir gefällt das optisch also nicht optisch so so vom style gefällt mir das überhaupt nicht schon
den ersten trailer den ich gesehen habe hat mir nicht gefallen von dem game so typ da mit der
maske drauf hat so richtig überhaupt nicht meins von der optik her don't starve ok ne
das brauche ich dann left oder 2 habe ich schon 7 ways zu was war denn das noch mal ach das war
so survival stels das ist wahrscheinlich auch early access was nie fertig wird ja das ist noch
im game aus zeiten von zombie stels das ist ja überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt jetzt zommi
zommi gerade jetzt ist battle royale angesagt
war es gut faumus jr.
forest das sagt mir irgendwas was war das noch mal ach das war auch so komisches survival stels
zeug das ding sieht aus wie aus dark messiah diese komischen golem forks die wir gestern
gegen die wir gestern gebasht haben was ist jetzt nicht geht noch weiter killing floor 2 da habe
ich die bittag gespielt mit dem mesh zusammen hat mich jetzt alles überzeugt aber ich bin ja
auch niemand für so zommi games also zommi wellen games hand showdown in einem erinnert
mich ein bisschen an call of jewel ress oder wie das wie das hieß früher ach nee das ist
der crytek das ist das ist das crytek pupke ne dass das crytek battle royale ist das
habe ich recht nur ist das das crytek battle royale doch nicht ich bin mir ein das ist das
crytek battle royale weil das wort royale kommt sich einmal drinnen vor in dem ach doch
ja wenn man die kommentare liest was ist das crytek battle royale taugt das was
mostly positive muss man nicht so viel geben ja crytek macht tatsächlich noch spieler
tritec hat halt wahrscheinlich sich jetzt gedacht ok wir müssen auch mal ein nachdem wir unseren
moba in sand gesetzt haben weil wir da viel zu spät dran waren müssen wir jetzt auch noch
einen battle royale machen wo wir viel zu spät dran sind crytek ist übrigens von mir
ja ich würde mal sagen so 300 meter luftlinie weg also wenn ich in frankfurt bin 300 meter
luftlinie ungefähr also mich würde nicht wundern wenn ich mit crytek leuten quasi
schon mittag gegessen hätte uns zu wissen so was haben wir hier noch horror games haben
die ihre entwickler inzwischen bezahlt war das crytek das war noch telltale die ihre entwickler
nicht bezahlt wahrscheinlich sind das alle die ihre entwickler nicht bezahlen also im gaming
bereich würde ich auch bei den meisten nicht arbeiten wollen ok horror games kenne ich nicht
das stimmt das ist das resident evil was mich total verwirrt was bei uns biohazard heißt und
bei in japan resident evil also bei uns heißt es biohazard bei uns heißt es resident evil
biohazard und dort heißt biohazard resident evil das ist das ist das ist ein sehr massiver
monka ist das das verwirrt mich immer wie rums jetzt geschrieben ist und das denn kript
oft in necrodance ist das allen es ist ein horror game das ist doch in den musikrhythmus spiel das
ist doch kein horror game kategorien in 2018 null kommt man das ist der raum 2 also es gibt nicht
nur ein raum es gibt zwei räume anscheinend was auch immer die namen von horror games werden auch
nicht besser das ist ganz gut aber auch schon älter das soll auch sehr nice sein wohl das
einzige alien spiel was irgendwie was taugt ja auch das war cool das kenne ich noch das war
cool ist aber auch schon uralt das game play das ist das ist das neu war play ist mittlerweile
kompliziert ist das das play von das ist das play von diesem jahr ok also von letztem jahr
gibt ja noch ein nicht allzu altes anderes play oder krümler ist auch ganz leise für
action RPG doch keine horror games was ist mit was ist mit steam los how to left for that abklatsch
logo nein nein was ganz was anderes was ist das das habe ich alleine dann schon 3 da fand ich in
die ersten zwei teile ganz cool aber tritt habe ich mal gefallen bayer schock nice bayer schock
nice ja irgendeines der vielen castlevanias da blicke ich den mal durch das war vor ein paar
jahren so neben slenderman das game wo sich alle immer fake erschreckt haben könnte euch könnte
euch noch ans länder erinnern wo sie dann alle rum rum rum gestellt sind und dann irgendwann
angefangen herum zu schreien um ein gott so richtig es war richtig richtig cringe ganzen videos
wenn die sich pass länder schon so eingeschissen haben die leute hätten immer vier spielen
müssen den ersten teil da sei das zwei das war auch ganz gut horror vr kommt jetzt das bringt
mir nix weil ich keine vr ab horror free to play nee das ist ja da weiß ich ja gar nicht was
ihr die horror davon ist ob horror oder ob free to play der horror ist ich glaube das ist auch sehr
unglücklich gewählt die überschrift oder findet ihr nicht auch horror free to play oder auch
genau der free to play horror und die games sehen auch ein schlimmer aus als das andere
wie war es das jetzt mehr moment da muss es doch noch mehr geben da sind nur die topseller
was haben wir sonst noch rutscher 3 ok das ist natürlich sehr nice kann man sich auf jeden
fall geben wenn man es noch nicht hat wenn man auf runden basiert der pg steht das ist wirklich
mittags non plus ultra in letzter zeit wirklich gut null gibt es das noch ich habe gehört dass
es mit einem der letzten updates ganz gut geworden ist wieso schaum von der tora spiel man weiß
es nicht was hältst du von informatik studium oder wirtschaft informatik wenn man mathe hasst
nichts also wenn du mathe hast und die auch mal quasi ein bisschen angeguckt hast vielleicht
mal so test ich test weil sich reingesetzt hast angehört hast da wirst du keinen spaß haben mit
jeglicher informatik den richard drei season pass
das ist auch eine spiele serie die voll an mir vorbei ging das war ja im prinzip das ist das
komplette fail game für mich so im endeffekt also das game was mir prinzipiell nicht gefallen
kann weil ich bin kein open world fan und das game hat ja außer sandbox open world gar nichts
das ist alles das wollte ich mir holen das wollte ich mir holen
das wollte ich mir holen das ganz nice das soll ja wohl eines der wenigen spiele sein die mittel
alter halbwegs realistisch darstellt da bin ich mir echt gespannt drauf das habe ich schon
das ist so ein game was auch keiner mehr spielt wahrscheinlich das war dieser tauchstell
jeder ich mich noch dunkel dran das metro bundle kann man sich mal holen was ist denn
im metro bundle alles dabei
na gut das erste metro habe ich ja schon
bioshock die habe ich auch schon alle gespielt
graveyard keeper das hatte auch einen guten start und sie haben es wohl auch komplett verschissen
outlast 2 das ist so resident sleeper game richtig resident sleeper game das wo sie wo
sie wieder alle wo sie alle wieder fürchten können so aber das ist nichts für mich das
ist viel zu langweilig hospital jetzt ist das so theme hospital abklatschen da habe
ich den trailer von gesehen was hat das für bewertungen schon wieder grafikstil zum davon
laufen ich habe prinzipiell nichts gegen comic grafikstil ja aber ich finde das ist mittlerweile
so inflationär ist irgendwie blizzard schafft zum beispiel wenn man sich so was wie overwatch
anguckt das hat trotz trotz das ist ja nicht wirklich comic look so extrem sondern das
hat halt was eigenes aber das ist immer das sieht so eins aus wie das andere von den games
jurassic world evolution nein und da war das dieser theme park das war diese theme park
geschichte aber das auch nicht auf schlechte bewertungen planet coaster city skylance das
soll ganz nahe sein wenn man auf dem city sachen steht ama 3 jetzt auch mit 15 fps
das habe ich schon was war das noch mal das war hier dieser das runen rumgestellt so war
das das war eigentlich ganz ok so wirklich viel gameplay hat es nicht gehabt und ich
glaube auch ein bisschen verwirrend aber so mal um in fünf stunden durchzuspielen war
schon ganz ok sag mal die haben nicht ernsthaft 743 seiten oder das kann ich mit ich kann
mir doch nicht 743 seiten angucken aber was ist was ist denn mit denen kaputt können
ich einfach masse statt klasse nein klassische klasse statt masse im zähl packen shadow warrior
2 das ist cool wer das noch nicht hat also das lohnt sich also wer das nicht hat 36
für leute oder für mich das wirklich cool also macht spaß
das lohnt sich auch wenn man auf dungeon keeper steht ist das richtig gut gibt immer neue
addons zu oder relativ viele also wenn man auf dungeon keeper wenn man bei deinem dungeon
keeper gefällt ist das cool dass für 65 kann man damit nichts nichts falsch machen schon
wieder dieses sage ich wollte noch nicht für den für den für dieses komische game ernsthaft
60 euro normalerweise haben er nicht hat ist auch super leider fehlt dem game einfach die
letzten paar kapitel weil sie die lc releasen wollten das heißt man muss sich eigentlich
die die edition kaufen mit allem drinne dass man es komplett sieht er ist eines der games
wo ich sagen muss das ist eines der spiele mit gehört zu meinen ich sag mal mindestens
top 10 was story technisch anbelangt das ganze ist echt cool gewesen also der der erste
das hier ist jetzt so ein abklatsch aber der war schon nice aber sam lake kann einfach
gute stories schreiben sam lake ist der typ der aussieht wie max payne er hat in teile
das wollte ich mir auch holen das soll auch ein ziemlich gutes jump run sein was hältst
du meinst die reaper changes keine ahnung habe ich mir nicht angeguckt spiel kein overwatch
mehr und wer das wahrscheinlich auch in nächster zeit erstmal nicht machen hast du jemals
winter 3 spiel ja ja klar 100 stunden oder so habts schon alles durch was hältst du
von den zug simulatoren für 250 nix ich das ist nichts was ich mir kaufen würde ich glaube
von diesen ganzen simulatoren ist glaube ich der landwirtschaft simulator noch der beste
wirst du dir cyberpunk holen wahrscheinlich schon ich hoffe dass es nicht zu viel sandbox
open world gestellt wird weil dann wirds mir nicht gefallen ich hoffe das wird ein bisschen
wie bei winter 3 da war ja im prinzip die sandbox auch also die open world auch mehr
oder weniger optional die main quest war übelst gut in winter 3 und die welt war auch gut
man konnte ein bisschen was drumherum machen aber es war jetzt nicht die nicht so das zentrale
von dem game doch schon aber sie hatten halt auch andere
sachen zu bieten in winter 3 als eben open world spiel die nur open world haben sowas
wie just cause oder so das halte ich nicht aus das kann ich nicht spielen das ist mir
einfach zu resident sleeper so just cause oder so das ist mir zu langweilig ich weiß
noch wo sie uns auf der games come in den just cause zeigen wollten wo es dann nicht
funktioniert hat also die wollten uns irgendwie zeigen just cause dann haben sie dich gespawnt
in so einem gebiet wo du angeblich dann ganz tolle sachen machen kannst ja und dann ging
es dann ging es am anfang nicht da war es da hat es irgendwie den panzer konntest du
den panzer rein mit dem panzer haben sie dann gesagt du solltest das teusch kaputt
gegangen es war es war richtig fail gibt es eigentlich noch moment gibt es eigentlich
von cooking mama mittlerweile eine neuauflage denn es hat denn hier hat es ja auch gesehen
gucken aber das ist das einzige casual game was ich stundenlang gespielt habe
gibt es da eigentlich was für ein 3ds mittlerweile wenigstens cooking mama 3 ja endlich da weiß
ich doch was ich mir noch für ein ds holen kann casual game schlechthin eigentlich das
größte kack casual game aber das spiele ich irgendwie gerne das so richtig dumm ist
das eigentlich richtig dummes game und ich habe es mir damals auf dem ds sogar nur geholt
weil ich mit meiner mit meiner wie ist das ding da wo man da wo man roms aus dem internet
rausspielen konnte runtergeladen habe ich hätte mir das nie gekauft den ersten teil
cooking mama nie weil ich bin ja auch so ein scheiß casual kack game spielst du eh nicht
dann habe ich mir runtergeladen und auf den wie ist das ding also in so eine karte zum
flaschen für den für den uralten ds habe ich angefangen zu spielen da habe ich das
quasi jeden tag paar stunden gespielt cooking mama total hängen geblieben
ds zt oder f4 f4 ich hatte zwei sachen genau ich hatte den f4 und irgendwie in den cyclo
ds oder wie dieses ding hieß kann ich ja genau das hat da konnte man so eine micro sd karte
rein machen und dann konnte man ds spiele spielen drauf ja das aber auch schon zehn
jahre her oder so aber richtig nice und ich hatte auch noch so ein teil da konnte man
vorne den gameboy advance slot faken auf dem auf dem ds der ds hat ja noch ein gameboy
advance slot und da konnte man da auch gameboy advance spiele drauf runterladen und so
hexo aber das ist der einzige grund warum ich der cooking mama gekauft habe danach
seit ich so das nie geholt stalker da haben sie doch jetzt noch einen zweiten teil angekündigt
da bin ich mal gespannt darauf wie der zweite zweiter zweiter stalker teil wird der ja bild
jetzt kommt es irgendwann mal aus early access raus das irgendwann mal aus early access raus
das game das ganze early access zeug ist einfach mittlerweile so übertrieben
ich habe manchmal das gefühl dass ich auch early access für den anbieter nicht richtig
lohnt wenn du halt ein game raushaust und das quasi schon zu release tot ist im endeffekt
obwohl es eigentlich das was du zeigen wolltest noch gar nicht hatte ich weiß nicht ob das
immer so eine gute idee ist die sachen im early access raus zu hauen so früh wie es
irgendwie geht warum gibt es für das game eigentlich den season pass gab es dafür
überhaupt jemals dlcs black mesa hier top also man kann das game zwar spielen im endeffekt
bisgründen aber childrens paste kann man das ja man kann es
Jetzt kommen aber nur noch Crap Games, oder? Ich glaube die guten haben wir jetzt durch.
Warum sind eigentlich auch keine Weep Games am Start gewesen? Die sind normalerweise auch bei solchen Sales immer vorne mit dabei.
Und die ganzen RPG Maker Games, wo sind die eigentlich? Die sind bei Sales auch immer vorne mit dabei.
Also, aber die meisten RPG Maker Sachen sind halt richtig Massive Crap, ja, ist richtiger Müll.
Ich habe gesagt, wo sind eigentlich die ganzen Crap Games?
Moment, davon gibt es ein Game? Okay, das ist wahrscheinlich schlecht.
Witcher 2 war es sehr nice. Ich bin ja jemand, der rote Fäden mag im Spiel, deswegen war Witcher 2 wirklich gut.
Witcher 2 war halt überhaupt nicht Open World.
Das hat eher so ein bisschen getan, als ob, aber es war halt null Open World.
Das fand ich ganz gut.
Warum ist sowas denn nicht weiter oben? Ich glaube, das wollen prinzipiell mehr Leute spielen, als irgendwie Simulator XY 2019.
Also irgendwie kommt jetzt wirklich nur Müll.
Wie teuer ist Witcher 2? Gucken wir mal.
2,99 Euro. Das kann man sich mal holen.
Das kann man sich mal holen, weil man es noch nicht gespielt hat. Das kann man nichts gegen sagen.
Ja, DOS 2 haben wir ja schon angepriesen vorher.
Das ist natürlich, wenn ich sage, es ist Schrott, es sah an, so war auch was Gutes dabei, aber das meiste auf der Seite ist Schrott.
Was ist denn das? Achso, das ist etwa Daylight DLC oder sowas.
Es gab übrigens letztens eine Beta oder Early Access oder sowas von dem neuen Fallout 76. Hat das jemand von euch gespielt?
Taugt das was? Ich habe bei Dens Gaming ein bisschen geguckt und das Kampfsystem sieht richtig langweilig und dumm aus.
Gerade bei Fallout sind wir halt Fallout 4 eigentlich so schlecht zur Bewertung. War davon abgesehen, außer dass es halt nicht gut ausschaut, aber sonst soll das doch gar nicht so schlecht gewesen sein.
Nie Automata, nein, habe ich nicht gespielt. Die sind nur stundenweise von 0 bis 4 morgens. Nee, das macht keiner freiwillig, das stimmt.
Komm, wir stalken jetzt mal, was der Meft so spielt. World War 3, 25 Stunden, GTA V, Find the Fuck, 1000 Stunden, Euro Truck Simulator, Alter, was ist los?
Jeder wieder will, jeder wieder will. Ich habe bestimmt auch genug Spaß an dem Profil.
Ja, now trending. Ja, das werde ich jetzt gleich umloggen und mir das nochmal holen. Das wollte ich mir nämlich die ganze Zeit schon kaufen.
Kingdome, Kome. Fallout 4 mit Mods macht mega Spaß. Wahrscheinlich ist es wieder ein Fallout, was ohne Mods keinen Bock macht.
Sie haben ja gesagt, dass es für das neue Fallout wird es keine Mods mehr geben. Da bin ich schon skeptisch, wenn ich sowas höre.
Wie lange müsst ihr das Studio ansehen? Ja, so einen Trecker braucht man. Wie findest du eigentlich Tanzverbot? Guck ich nicht, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Also spätestens in einer halben Stunde muss ich eh aufstehen. Ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock, ehrlich gesagt. Überhaupt keinen Bock.
Aber es sind ja nur 4 Tage. Ich werde 3 Tage frei. Eats. Und im Dezember geht es ab, Leute. Das sage ich euch.
Im Dezember bin ich den ganzen Monat da. Da werden wir jeden Tag streben. Naja, ob wir das jeden Tag machen, weiß ich nicht.
Aber relativ viel streben und bestimmt auch die anderen Videos mal wieder machen. Black Ops 2 ist aber down. Weiß nicht.
Es ist möglich, dass ich gedacht habe, wir schalten es einfach mal ab. Es ist halt auch im Prinzip Fail, wenn man sich anguckt, wie viel Geld man da teilweise ausgeben konnte.
Mit irgendwelchen Boxen und Zeugs und jetzt ist es weg, weil das nicht mehr relevant ist in dem Game. Und sich nicht transferieren lässt.
Weiß eigentlich jemand, wie das in FIFA ist? Ich habe das noch nie gespielt. Also seit es da Microtransaction und Gedöns gibt.
Mal angenommen, ich habe jetzt FIFA 2018 und ich habe jetzt da das mega krasse Team. Und ich habe da irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 2000 Euro reingesteckt, dass ich mal ein geiles Team kriege.
Habe ich davon noch was, wenn FIFA 2019 rauskommt oder ist es dann einfach instant weg?
Hast du gesagt, das nächste Fallout Elder Scrolls soll ohne Mod sein? Das nächste Elder Scrolls, keine Ahnung. Aber das nächste Fallout soll ohne Mod sein.
Alles weg, na geil. Also wieder 2000 Euro reinstecken, yeah. Alter, warum machen die Leute das? Ich verstehe es nicht. Ich verstehe das nicht.
Was hältst du von Windforms für kleine Tools? Perfekt. Oder doch, plattformübergreifend und cute nur, wenn es Windows Only sein muss, ist Windows Forms perfekt für kleine Zeug.
Alter, da müssten doch Leute schon tausende ausgegeben haben für die letzten paar Fifas, oder?
Eliqo36, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht weil ich keine Qualitätsoptionen habe. Ich weiß nicht.
Habt ihr das gesehen, weil es gerade um FIFA Esports ging, wo letztens der Typ ragedquittert hat mitten im Turnier? Wegen dem Turnier hat einer ragedquittert.
Fast so geil wie der Typ, der in StarCraft mit dem Fuß gespielt hat und gewonnen hat. Ist jetzt kein Witz, ne? Das war wirklich, da hat wirklich einer in StarCraft mit dem Fuß gespielt.
Kann mir irgendwie erklären, wie Amazon bis morgen Abend mein Paket so schicken will, funktioniert das? Wenn das bei Amazon da steht, dann funktioniert das meistens auch.
Es sei denn DHL oder Hermes. Also Hermes ist immer so eine Sache. Wobei ich sagen muss, Hermes klappt bei uns mittlerweile ganz gut. Bei DPD ist es immer so eine Sache und UPS kannst du eh vergessen. Aber mit DHL klappt das in der Regel.
Es gibt bei uns jetzt sogar Evening Express. Nee, nicht Evening Express. Same Day Express? Oder wie das heißt, wo dann irgendein Typ von Amazon losfährt und das bei dir vorbeibringt. Bestellste und ein paar Stunden später ist der Kram da.
Die Evening Express ist das für Weihnachten, wo du irgendwie 45 Euro Versand bezahlst oder sowas. Aber gut, wenn du so spät bist, musst du da halt einen sauren Apfel beißen lassen. Einfach Pech.
Ja, das war halt Programming technisch nicht so wahnsinnig ergiebig. Aber wir haben wieder schön Zeug geschwätzt. So muss das sein.
Ja, gut. Dann würde ich sagen, mache ich jetzt Schluss. Wir sehen uns demnächst. Macht's gut. Bis dann. See you.